İyi akşamlar arkadaşlar 20 Eylül 2024 Cuma günü 29. ders günümüz saat 19.30 dersimize başlıyoruz kaldığımız yerden devam edeceğiz ses ya da görüntüde problem olursa bildirin lütfen değerli arkadaşlar.
Dün de söylediğimiz gibi bugün artık kursun ikinci yarısını başlatıyoruz tabii süre olarak yarısını tamamlamış değiliz ama konu içeriği açısından bence ikinci bölüm olmayı hak ediyor çünkü artık bugün pointerlar konusuyla devam edeceğiz.
C dilini öğrenmeyi biraz zorlaştıran fakat C dilini diğer dillerden de büyük ölçüde ayrı kılan dilin en önemli araçlarından biri olan adres kavramıyla tanışacağız.
Arkadaşlar öncelikle şunu söyleyerek başlayalım pointer sözcüğüne özel bir anlam yüklemeyin pointer demek adres demek.
Yani C ya da C++ dilleri bağlamında okuduğunuz herhangi bir metinde dinlediğiniz herhangi bir konuşmada pointer sözcüğü geçtiği zaman onun yerine adres sözcüğünü koyun cümlenin anlamında bir değişiklik olmaz diyebiliriz.
Yani pointer adres anlamında kullanılan biraz teknik bir terim.
Kursun birinci bölümünde biz daha çok nesnelerin değerleriyle ilgilendik.
Değişkenlerin değerlerini fonksiyonlara gönderdik.
Değişkenlerin değerlerini değiştirdik.
Fonksiyonlardan geri dönüş değeri olarak değişkenlerin değerini aldık.
Dizilerimiz oldu en son.
Dizilerin elemanlarında değerler tuttuk.
Fakat kursun ikinci yarısında daha çok işimiz değişkenlerin, nesnelerin değerleriyle değil adresleriyle.
İkinci yarıda öğreneceğimiz araçlarla örneğin değişkenlerin adreslerini değişkenlerde tutacağız.
Öyle değişkenlerimiz olacak ki onların değerleri adres olacak.
Fonksiyonlara adresleri argüman olarak göndereceğiz.
Fonksiyonlardan geri dönüş değeri olarak adresler alacağız.
Bizlilerin elemanları adres tutan değişkenleri olacak.
Çok sayıda alt başlığımız olacak fakat alt başlıklarımızdan, alt başlıklarımızın hepsi değil ama önemli çoğunluğu doğrudan ya da dolaylı adreslerle ilgili olacak.
Bunu baştan söyleyelim.
Arkadaşlar, C dilinde pointer sözcüğü az önce söylediğim gibi adres anlamında kullanılan bir terim.
Fakat C ve C++ dilleri adresleri öncelikle statik tür sisteminde iki ayrı kategoriye ayırıyor.
Kategorilerden birini İngilizce'de Object Pointers, diğerine ise Function Pointers diyor.
Yani Object Pointers, nesnelerin adresleri, nesne değişken aynı anlamda kullandığımızı hatırlayın.
Nesnelerin adresleri, Function Pointers ise adı üstünde fonksiyonların adresleri.
Fonksiyonların adresleriyle görece olarak daha geç tanışacağız ama önce nesnelerin adresleriyle tanışacağız.
Her ikisi de önemli konu, her ikisi de C ve C++ dillerinde önemli araçlar.
Arkadaşlar, özellikle yüksek seviyeli dillerde adres dil katmanında olan bir varlık değil.
Yani donanımsal olarak bir adresten bahsedebiliriz.
Assemble kodu olarak bir adresten bahsedebiliriz.
Ama dilin seviyesi yükseldikçe, dilin kendi sentaksında ve semantik yapısında doğrudan adresler kullanılmıyor.
Bu da kötü bir şey değil.
Çünkü adres daha çok donanıma yakın bir kavram.
Adresleri dil katmanına koymak, programcının soyutlama, abstraction yapmasını zorlaştırıyor.
Fakat CD'nin kullanıldığı alanlarda, domenlerde zaten tipik olarak donanıma yakın uygulamalar.
Örneğin sistem programlama, gömülü sistem programlama gibi.
Ve burada dil katmanında adres kavramının olması aslında o uygulama domenine yakışıyor.
Orayı daha iyi resmediyor, temsil ediyor.
Yani uygulama tarafına doğru gittikçe adreslerin içinde olması rahatsız edici.
Ama donanım tarafına doğru gittikçe adreslerin dil katmanında, dilde araç olarak yer alması kötü bir şey olmayabilir.
Bu konu biraz da tartışmaya açık.
Ama biz şimdi yavaş yavaş bir giriş yapalım.
Adreslerin dilde olması ne demek?
Buradan başlayalım.
Bunu şöyle düşünmelisiniz.
Bizim dildeki, CD'lindeki temel birimlerimizden biri neydi?
Belki de en temel birim, token'dan sonra.
Expression.
Yani ifade.
Arkadaşlar, hatırlıyorsunuz, ifadelerin türleri vardı CD'linde.
C++'da da öyle.
Bir ifadeyi niteleyen bence 3-4 tane önemli terim.
İfadenin türü, yani İngiliz cinsiz ile data type'ı.
İfadenin value kategorisi, yani ifadenin L value ya da R value olması ve doğal olarak bir de ifadenin nesi, değeri.
O zaman adres dil katmanında kullanılacak bir kavram ise, öyle ifadeler olmalı ki, o ifadelerin türü bir adres belirtmesi belirtmeli.
Gerçekten de böyle.
Yani örneğin ben size şöyle bir soru sorsaydım.
Arkadaşlar, int x eşittir 5.
x ifadesinin türü nedir diye sorsaydım, int diyecektiniz.
x artı 5 ifadesinin türü nedir diye sorsaydım, yine int diyecektiniz.
x artı 5.6 ifadesinin türü nedir diye sorsaydım, double diyecektiniz.
Şimdi, biraz ilerledikten sonra, ben bu ifadenin türü nedir diye sorduğumda,
cevabınızın olası kümesi içinde ne de var, bu ifadenin türü bir adrestir diyebilirsiniz.
Yani, öyle ifadeler olacak ki, o ifadeler adres türlerinden olacak.
Dil bir tasarım, farklı diller, farklı şekilde tasarlanmış olabilirler.
Örneğin, adresin bir türü olduğunu söyledik, pek hala şöyle olabilirdi.
Buradaki tasarım iyi ya da kötü anlamında söylemiyorum.
Hangi türden değişken olursa olsun, o değişkenin adresi, aynı türden bir ifade olabilirdi.
Yani, adres diye tek bir tür var.
intürden x'in adresi de o türden, double türden d var.
İsimli değişkenin adresi de o türden, böyle bir tasarım yapılabilirdi.
Ama böyle değil.
Öncelikle, böyle olmadığını söyleyerek başlayalım.
Peki, nasıl arkadaşlar?
Sorunun cevabı şöyle.
Arkadaşlar, bir adres türü, hangi türden değişkenin adresi olduğuyla ilgili?
Yani, bu cümleye dikkat, farklı türlerden, değişkenlerin adresleri olan ifadeler, farklı türden ifadeler.
Bu çok önemli bir cümle.
Bu ne demek?
intürden bir nesne adresi ile Musa, double türden bir nesne adresi, bunlar iki ayrı ifade olsun.
Bu iki ifadenin türü aynı mı, farklı mı?
Cevap farklı.
Yani, bu şu demek.
Buraya dikkat.
Diyelim ki, şimdiye kadar, öğrendiğimiz tam sayı ve gerçek sayı türleri vardı ya,
öğrendiğimiz her farklı tam sayı, gerçek sayı türü için, o türe ilişkin bir de adres türü var.
Örneğin, çar bir tür değil mi?
O zaman, çar türden nesne adresi, türü de bir tür.
int bir tür değil mi?
intürden bir nesnenin adresi anlamına gelen ifadenin türü de farklı bir adres türü.
Matematikte aksiyon ne demek?
Konu nereden buraya geldi, açıklayacağım.
Arkadaşlar, aksiyon şu anlamda kullanılıyor değil mi?
Yani, kanıtlama zorunluluğu olmadan doğru kabul edilen cümleler, ifadeler.
C'de de, pointerlar konusuna girdiğimizde, şöyle bir adeta aksiyonla tanışalım önce.
X, t türünden bir değişken olsun.
Burada t derken ne kastettiğimi herkes anlıyor değil mi?
Yani, t'nin ne olduğunun konuyla ilgisi yok.
Örneğin, x intürden bir değişken olsun, x doubletürden bir değişken olsun gibi.
Yani, t tür sisteminde var olan bir türü ifade ediyor.
Eğer bir ifade, yani bir expression, x değişkeninin adresi anlamına geliyorsa,
bu ifadenin türü, işte aksiyonumuza geldik, t yıldız olarak ifade ediliyor.
Şimdi, önce bu aksiyonumu anlamanızı istiyorum.
Soruya cevap vermeye çalışın.
Int türden bir değişkenin adresi anlamına gelen ifadenin türü ne bizim tür sistemimizde?
Cevap, bravo, int yıldız.
Double türden bir nesnenin adresi anlamına gelen ifadenin türü, double yıldız.
Çar türden bir nesnenin adresi anlamına gelen ifadenin türü, çar, yıldız.
Anlaşıldı mı?
Yani, eğer bir nesnenin türünden bahsediyorsak, o tür t ise,
aynı nesnenin adresi anlamına gelen ifadenin türü t, yıldız.
Burayı anlamamız son derece önemli arkadaşlar.
Herkes burayı anladı mı?
Demek ki, tek bir adres türü yok.
Böyle de olabilirdi.
Dedik ya başta.
Çar türden bir nesnenin adresi ayrı bir adres türü,
dolayısıyla ayrı bir tür,
flot türden bir nesnenin adresi ayrı bir tür.
Arkadaşlar, derleyiciye bağlı olmakla birlikte,
sistemlerde object pointer türlerinin storage ihtiyacı aynı.
Örneğin, benim derleyicimde bütün adres türleri 4 byte.
Yani ben, değeri adres olan bir değişken tanımlamak istesem,
o değişken benim derleyicimde 4 byte yer kaplayacak.
Şimdi çok dikkatli izliyorsunuz.
Geldik, işin yavaş yavaş zor kısımda.
Şunların hepsi birer tür değil mi?
Int yıldız bir tür,
çar yıldız bir tür,
long yıldız bir tür.
Arkadaşlar, pratik bir söylemle,
ben Türkçe'de daha çok bunu kullanmayı tercih ediyorum.
Bu türlerden, yani adres türlerinden bahsederken,
int yıldız, çar yıldız, long yıldız,
yani doğrudan o türü anlatan tokenlar neyse onları okuyorum.
Fakat İngilizce'de,
bu türü sözel olarak ifade etmek gerektiğinde,
kullanılan terminoloji şöyle,
pointer to int.
Yani int türden bir nesnenin adresi olan türün ismi ne?
Pointer to int.
Yani int yıldız demekle,
pointer to int türü demek arasında,
bir fark olmadığını düşünmelisiniz.
Bu türün ismi ne?
Pointer to char.
Pointer to long.
Takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Evet.
Arkadaşlar, çok dikkatli izleyelim şimdi.
Nasıl int türden bir değişken tanımladığımız zaman,
böyle bir değişkenin değeri int türden ise,
yani bu bir işaretli tam sayı değerini taşıyacak değişken ise,
adres türlerinden de değişkenler tanımlayabiliyoruz.
Örneğin,
birazdan öğreneceğimiz sentaksla,
bu şekilde bir değişken tanımladığımızda,
bunu şu şekilde ifade edebiliriz.
ptr'nin türü int yıldız,
ya da ptr'nin türü pointer to int.
yani ptr değişkeni değeri int türden bir nesne adresi olan değişken.
Bakın ilk defa böyle değişkenlerle tanışıyoruz.
ptr değeri int nesne adresi olan bir değişken.
Arkadaşlar,
bu değişkenler canlı olsaydı,
örneğin İval'e sorsaydım,
sevgili İval,
senin değerin ne?
O bize belki diyecekti ki,
abi benim değerim 10, 20,
eksi 5.
Ama ptr'ye,
sevgili ptr,
senin değerin ne diye sorduğumuzda,
o bize ne diyecek?
Abi benim değerim int türden,
x değişkeninin adresi,
y değişkeninin adresi.
Yani ptr'nin değeri,
int türden bir değişkenin adresi.
değişkenimizi şu şekilde tanımlasaydık,
double yıldız örneğin dp,
bp'nin varlık nedenini,
double türden bir değişkenin adresini tutmak.
Yani örneğin,
böyle bir değişkende,
sadece ve sadece int türden nesne adresini tutabiliriz,
tutmalıyız,
evet.
Ya da soruyu tersinden soralım,
diyelim ki,
ileride öğreneceğimiz,
işleri,
amaçları gerçekleştirmek için,
float türden bir değişkenin,
adresini tutacak değişkene ihtiyacım var.
Nasıl tanımlayacağım değişkeni?
float yıldız,
x gibi.
Arkadaşlar,
ben,
üretimden bağımsız,
şimdi kodlar yazdığım için,
sizin de daha kolay takip edebilmenizi sağlamak adına,
değişkenler,
pointer değişkenlerse,
bunların ismini,
p ile başlatacağım,
bazen ptr yapacağım,
bazen bir önek koyup,
sonuna p koyacağım.
Yani içinde p isminin geçmesi,
p harfinin geçmesi,
bunların pointer değişkenleri olduğu algısını,
siz de kuvvetlendirecek.
Böylece daha iyi takip edebileceksiniz.
isimlendirme konvensiyonları üstüne,
daha sonra tekrar konuşacağız.
Şimdi bakın,
ilk soruyla başlayalım.
Arkadaşlar,
burada kaç tane token var?
Soru bir.
Cevap,
üç tane.
Keyword,
arkadaşlar,
bu ne?
Deklaratör,
öyle değil mi?
Bu ise,
arkadaşlar,
identifier.
Peki,
bana pointerler konusunu anlattığımda,
ilk sorulan,
böyle dediğim için kusura bakmayın,
kötü soru şu,
Necati böyle yazsak olur mu?
Arkadaşlar,
bunlar token.
Dolayısıyla,
sentaks açısından,
örneğin,
az önceki değişkeni,
böyle tanımlasam da,
kodun anlamında,
bir değişiklik olur mu?
Tokenizing,
aynı şekilde yapılacak.
dolayısıyla,
eğer siz bana,
burada,
legalite soruyorsanız,
kötü bir soru.
Ha,
yok ben legaliteye sormuyorum,
konvensyonel olarak,
nasıl,
tanımlama,
yaygın diyorsanız,
valla tek bir konvensyon yok.
Daha yaygın konvensyon,
arkadaşlar,
asterisk token'ın,
tür belirten,
sözcüğe bitişik yazılması.
yani ben de,
çoğunlukla bunu kullanıyorum.
Int,
yıldız,
örneğin p.
Ama,
böyle yazmak yerine,
örneğin,
şöyle yazanlarda var mı?
Int,
yıldız p.
Böyle yazan da var,
bazen de ben,
öyle yazıyorum.
Ama da bazen de böyle yazıyorum derken,
bir öyle,
bir böyle değil.
Yani,
her zaman,
istikrar,
arkadaşlar,
stabilite,
önemli.
Demek istediğim şu,
ister 5. satırdaki gibi tanımlayın,
ister 6. satırdaki gibi tanımlayın,
ister 7. satırdaki gibi tanımlayın,
anlamsal açıdan,
Ömer Kara,
Oğuz Surgut,
Cengiz Zor görmez,
hiçbir farklılık yok.
Anlaşıldı değil mi?
İkinci üstünde durmak istediğim nokta,
başlangıçta,
bunu daha önce de konuşmuştuk.
Arkadaşlar,
programcıların,
ya da programcı adaylarının,
bazen profesyonel düzeyde de bunun karıştırıldığını görüyorum.
Operatörle,
İngilizce kullanılan sözcük,
operator biliyorsunuz.
Deklaratörün,
declarator,
birbiriyle karıştırılması.
Soru,
bu bir ifade mi?
Cevap,
hayır.
Bu bir bildirim,
bu bir declaration,
declaration statement.
Dolayısıyla,
burada bir ifade söz konusu değil.
O zaman,
ortada bir ifade yoksa,
oradaki token'ın,
operatör olma ihtimali var mı?
Cevap,
hayır.
Dolayısıyla,
bazen kitaplarda da bu hatanın yapıldığını görüyorum.
Buradaki asterisk token'ı,
bir operatör mü?
Cevap,
hayır.
Asla.
Bu bir operatör değil.
eğer,
bir token,
bir declaration'da,
bir varlığın,
türünü belirtmek için kullanılıyorsa,
öyle token'ları,
C ve C++ dillerinde,
ben Türkçe,
bildirici,
bildirgeç diye bir sözcük kullanmaya teşebbüs etmiştim.
Biraz komik karşılandı.
Arkadaşlar,
İngilizce,
declarator deniyor.
ben Türkçe eleştirip,
sanki Türkçe'ye sözcükmüş gibi,
deklaratör de diyorum.
Anlaşıldı değil mi?
Ama diyelim ki,
birkaç ders ilerledik,
ve şöyle bir ifadeyle karşılaştık.
Kodun ne anlama geldiğinden bağımsız olarak.
Arkadaşlar,
şimdi burada soru,
bir bildirim var mı?
Ömer Osman Koyuncu,
Emin Güncü,
Ahmet Özkan,
hayır.
O zaman buradaki asterisk atomu ile ilgili,
tek ihtimal ne?
Bunun bir operatör olması.
Bu ikisi birbiriyle karıştırılıyor.
Dolayısıyla bakın,
buradaki yıldız,
operatör değil,
ama burada bir ifade olduğu için,
buradaki yıldız,
asterisk bir operatör.
Az önce,
pointer değişkenlerin,
derleyicilerde,
object pointer değişkenlerin,
storage ihtiyacının,
aynı olduğunu söylemiştim.
Aynı derken,
yani bir derleyicide,
örneğin,
int nesne adresi,
türünün,
size of değerinin,
char nesne adresi türünün,
size of değeriyle,
aynı olduğunu kastediyorum.
Bunu bir göstermek istiyorum.
Arkadaşlar,
mesela,
benim derleyicimde,
object pointer türleri,
4 byte.
bakınız arkadaşlar,
char türünün,
size of değeri,
char yıldız türünün,
size of değeri.
Söyleyin,
bende char türünün,
size of değeri ne?
Hem bütün derleyicilerde,
zaten 1 byte değil mi?
Ama char yıldız türünün,
size of değeri,
pointer size of,
object pointer size of,
bende 4 byte.
tabi sizin derleyicinizde,
örneğin,
8 byte olabilir.
Mesela,
şu anda,
benim settingimde,
bunu değiştireyim.
Arkadaşlar,
8 byte.
Ama şimdi,
4 byte'lık settinge,
geleceğim.
Kafanız karışmasın.
Evet.
Yani,
şimdi,
bu ne demek?
Başka bir türe bakalım.
Short türü kaç byte?
2 byte bende.
Ama,
short yıldız türü kaç byte?
Cevap,
yine 4 byte.
Bende,
int türü 4 byte.
Arkadaşlar,
int yıldız türü de 4 byte.
Bende,
long türü 4 byte.
Long yıldız türü de 4 byte.
Yani,
long nesne adresi türü de 4 byte.
Efendim,
bende,
plot türü 4 byte.
Plot yıldız türü de 4 byte.
Ama mesela,
buraya bakın,
arkadaşlar,
long long türü,
8 byte.
Ama,
long,
star,
long long yıldız türü,
yine 4 byte.
Bütün pointer türlerinin,
4 byte olduğunu görüyorsunuz.
Arkadaşlar,
son olarak,
double türü ne de bakalım.
Double türü,
8 byte.
Ama,
double yıldız türü,
4 byte.
yani,
eğer,
bir değişkeniniz,
object pointer türlerinden ise,
o değişkeniniz,
bellek de,
aynı miktarda yer kaplıyor,
diğer object pointer türleriyle.
İşte,
o değer,
benim derleyicim de,
4 byte.
Peki,
Necati,
object pointer türleriyle,
function pointer türlerinin,
her ne kadar daha,
function pointer türlerine,
epey yolumuz olsa da,
aynı miktarda yer kapladığını,
söyleyebilir miyiz?
Hayır.
Böyle bir garanti yok.
Örneğin,
sistemde,
nesne adresi türleri,
4 byte iken,
fonksiyon adresi türleri,
8 byte olabilir.
Bu sefer,
biraz daha düzenli gideceğim.
Kodları,
mümkün olduğu kadar,
yapıştıracağım.
Tempoyu da,
bozmamaya gayret ederek.
Şimdi,
devam.
Çok dikkatli izleyin.
Arkadaşlar,
soruyu,
önce anlamaya çalışın,
sonra birlikte cevaplayacağız.
Ben size,
birkaç tane ifade yazacağım.
Tamam.
Daha yazmadım.
Bunlar bildirimler.
Siz bana,
bu ifadelerin,
türlerinden,
bahsedeceksiniz.
Yani,
o ifadelerin,
türlerini söyleyeceksiniz.
Anlaştık mı?
Evet.
Soruyorum.
bu ifadenin türü ne?
Cevap int.
Eğer bu ifadenin,
türünün neden int olduğunu,
bilmiyorsanız,
muhtemelen,
sabitlerle ilgili dersimizi,
izlememiş ya da,
unutmuş olabilirsiniz.
Devam.
Bu ifadenin türü ne?
cevap,
yine int.
Bu ifadenin tür ne?
Cevap,
yine int.
Öyle değil mi?
Peki,
biraz değiştirelim.
A köşeli parantez 3.
Bu ifadenin türü ne?
Bu da int.
Hayır,
daha int yıldızdan hiç bahsetmedim.
Bu da int.
Peki,
bu ifadenin türü ne?
Cevap,
bu da int.
anlaşıldı mı?
Evet.
Bu garajı,
şimdi anlatmayacağım.
Zaten,
aynı olma garantisi yok.
Aynı olamaz demedim.
Fonksiyon adresleri,
ve değişken adresleri,
aynı size of değerinde olabilir.
Ama olmak zorunda değil.
Mesela benim derleyicimde aynı.
Evet.
Şimdi buradan şunu anlatmaya çalıştığımı,
tahmin ediyorsunuz.
Arkadaşlar,
bu ifadeler aslında,
doğrudan da birbirine benzemiyor.
Mesela bir sabit,
bir değişken ismi,
aritmetik bir işlem var.
Bizinin bir elemanına gelişiyorum.
Bir fonksiyon çağrı ifadesi.
Ama,
bu ifadelerin hepsinin,
türü int.
Ama şimdi,
ben size bir soru daha sorsam.
Lütfen dikkat.
İfadeleri nitereyen,
önemli bir,
terim daha vardı.
Her ne kadar C'de bu terim açıkça kullanılmasa,
C++'ın önemli terimi.
Value category.
Value category ne demekti?
İfadenin,
ifadenin L value ya da R value olması.
Şimdi söyleyin bakalım,
yanlışlık yapmaktan da çekinmeden,
her bir ifadenin,
L value ya da R value olup olmadığını,
söylemenizi istiyorum.
Evet,
L ya da R yazabilirsiniz.
11. satırdaki ifade,
L value mu,
R value mu?
Cevap,
R value.
Bu ifade,
11,
12,
L value.
Bu ifade,
arkadaşlar,
cevap,
R value.
Bu ifade,
bizim elemanına erişme ifadesi olduğuna göre,
L value.
Bu ifade,
cevap,
R value alıyor.
Bravo.
Arkadaşlar,
buradan nereye gönderme yapacağımı tahmin eder misiniz?
Şimdi biz biraz daha ilerlediğimiz zaman,
şöyle bir durumla karşılaşacağız.
Benzer soruyu soracağım size,
ama bayağı bir şey öğrendikten sonra,
yine ifadeler yazacağım,
ve yine aynı soruyu sorduğumda,
nasıl şimdi bu ifadelerin türünün int olduğunu soruyorsanız,
daha sonra soracağım bir soruda da int yıldız diyeceksiniz.
Yani burada vurgulamak istediğim şu,
int türden ifadeler,
farklı biçimlerde karşımıza çıkabiliyor,
değil mi?
Evet.
Ama hepsinin ortak noktası,
bunların int olması.
ve bazı int türden ifadeler,
R value expression can,
bazı int türden ifadeler,
L value expression,
değil mi?
Adres türleri için de böyle.
Mesela,
biraz ilerlediğimiz zaman,
şu anda bilmediğinizi varsayarak anlatıyorum,
bu ifadenin türünün de int yıldız,
hatta hatta izleyin,
hiç anlamaya çalışmayın,
bu ifadenin türünün de int yıldız,
hatta hatta,
bakın bakın,
int yıldız p a,
kodu anlamaya çalışmayın,
bu ifadenin türünün de int yıldız olduğunu söyleyeceksiniz.
Yani nasıl int türden ifadeler,
farklı farklı görüntülerle karşımıza çıkabiliyor ise,
türü int yıldız olan ifadelerde,
farklı biçimlerde karşımıza çıkacaklar.
Bundan bahsettim.
Çok yakında bu noktaya kadar ilerleyeceğiz.
Şimdi,
yine dikkat etmenizi istiyorum.
Şu pointer değişkenlerimize geri dönelim.
Arkadaşlar,
böyle bir değişken ne anlama geliyordu?
Bu öyle bir değişken ki,
bu değişkenin değeri,
int türden bir değişkenin adresi.
Yani biz,
bu değişkeni bir ifade içinde kullandığımızda,
bu ifadenin değeri,
dolayısıyla bu değişkenin değeri,
int türden bir nesnenin adresi anlamına gelecek.
Arkadaşlar,
burada yalnız,
biraz sizi,
belki,
zorlayacak demeyeyim ama,
beklentinizin dışında,
olduğu için,
şaşırtacak bir kural var.
Eğer,
ben şöyle demiştim,
değil mi?
P değişkeninin türü int yıldız.
Eğer şimdi yapacağım açıklamayı,
yapmayacak olsaydım,
ve size şöyle bir kod,
böyle bir bildirim yapsaydım,
yani comma separated list ile,
muhtemelen,
konuyla ilk defa tanışan arkadaşlar,
daha önceden sizi bilmeyenler tabii,
işte Necati İnk Yıldız'ın bir türü olduğunu söyledi.
O zaman bu bir türse,
buradaki değişkenler de aynı türden.
Böyle bir beklentiye gireceklerdi.
Fakat burada kural böyle değil.
Arkadaşlar,
bildirimlerde kullanılan bu deklaratör dediğimiz tokenlar,
ki örneğin dizi bildirimlerindeki köşeli parantezle bir deklaratör,
birgürlerle ayrılmış listede,
değişkenlerin hepsini,
listedeki değişkenlerin hepsini değil,
sadece önüne ya da arkalarına geldikleri isimleri niteliyorlar.
Dolayısıyla böyle bir bildirim yaptığımda,
bu aslında şu anlamda,
int bunların hepsini niteliyor Musa,
yani p1'i de, p2'i de, p3'ü de,
ama asterisk atomu int'e yapışık yazsam da,
sadece kimi niteliyor Musa?
p1'i.
Yani,
burada aynı bildirimi,
comma separated list kullanmadan ayrı ayrı yapsaydım,
yukarıdakinin karşılığı şu olacaktı,
int yıldız p1,
int p2,
int p3.
Burayı anlamanız önemli.
anlaşılır değil mi?
6. satırdaki,
comma separated list ile yapılan bildirim,
7, 8 ve 9. satırlarda yapılan bildirime eşdeğer.
Bartank'ta bu,
biraz programcıların kafasını karıştırıyor.
Ben mümkün olduğu kadar,
kişisel olarak,
comma separated list ile bildirim yapma,
taraftarı değilim.
Gözü biraz zorluyor,
hata yapma riskini,
arttırıyor.
Ama burayı anladığınızı umuyorum.
Yani,
p2,
int türden bir değişken mi?
Yoksa,
int yıldız türden bir değişken mi?
Cevap,
p2,
int türden bir değişken.
Bravo.
Bu,
özellikle başlangıç seviyesinde,
tipik bir,
yanlış anlama noktası.
Şimdi,
biraz daha değiştireyim bildirimi.
Biraz daha,
kafanızı karıştırmak isteyeyim.
Bakın,
dizilerde de böyle.
int x,
y,
z,
h.
Bu bildirimde,
santaks açısından bir hata var mı?
Uğur Ün,
Salih Çolakoğlu.
Cevap,
hayır.
Ama,
burada,
köşeli parantez bir deklaratör değil mi?
Burada da köşeli parantez,
arkasına geldiği,
arkadaşlar,
ismi niteliyor.
Yani,
burada y'yi niteliyor,
burada t'yi niteliyor.
Dolayısıyla,
buradaki bildirimi,
comma separated liste değil de,
ayrı ayrı,
her bir değişkeni,
ayrı bir declaration statement ile bildirseydim,
int x,
int y,
3,
int z ve,
int t köşeli parantez 10 olacaktı.
Anlaşıldı mı?
Umut Yağmur,
evet.
Peki,
devam ediyoruz.
Şimdi,
biraz daha karıştıralım,
arkadaşlar,
ve şöyle bir şey yazalım,
int,
yıldız,
p1,
buraya dikkat,
arkadaşlar,
p2,
efendim,
p3,
yıldız,
p4,
isimlere bakmayın.
Takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Evet.
Arkadaşlar,
bakın yine,
buradaki int p1'i de,
p2'i de,
p3'i de,
p4'ü de niteliyor.
Ama,
buradaki yıldız,
sadece p1'i,
sadece p4'ü,
buradaki köşeli parantez ise,
p2'yi niteliyor.
Şimdi,
bana,
söyleyebilir misiniz,
tek tek değişkenleri,
ayrı,
declaration statement ile tanımlayın,
int,
yıldız p1,
bu bir.
int p2,
köşeli parantez 10,
bu iki.
int p3,
bu üç.
Arkadaşlar,
int yıldız p4,
bu dört.
Anlaşıldı mı?
Hatta,
bana soru sormamak kaybıyla,
biraz daha örneği karıştırayım.
İzleyin.
int x,
köşeli parantez 5,
yıldız y,
yıldız z,
köşeli parantez 4.
Arkadaşlar,
tamam,
Necati,
şunu anladık da,
bu ne?
diyebilirsiniz,
henüz tabii ki anlatmadım,
ileride göreceğiz.
Bakın,
burada yıldız,
yıldız da,
köşeli parantez de,
aynı ismini niteliyor.
yani,
hem köşeli parantez,
o bir deklaratör,
hem de asterisk bir deklaratör.
Yani,
her ikisi de z'nin türüyle ilgili.
Ki,
biraz ilerlediğimizde,
gelecek haftalarda,
ileride,
üç vakte kadar,
bunun şu anlama geldiğini göreceğiz.
int x köşeli parantez 5,
int yıldız y,
int yıldız z köşeli parantez 4.
Peki,
bunu da geçtik.
Şimdi gelelim,
yavaş yavaş,
önemli sorulara.
Soru 1,
Neco,
şimdi,
böyle bir türden değişken,
otomatik ömürlü bir yerel değişken olabiliyor,
statik ömürlü bir yerel değişken olabiliyor,
global bir değişken olabiliyor,
bir fonksiyonun,
parametre değişkeninin türü olabiliyor,
oyun tartörlerinde de aynı mı?
Cevap,
evet.
Yani bu açıdan,
pointer türlerinden değişkenlerin,
bir farkı yok.
Ne demek istiyorum,
bakınız.
Burada,
tanımladığım değişken,
global namespace de tanımlandığına göre,
bu bir global değişken değil mi?
Ama türü int değil de int yıldız.
Yani pekala bir pointer değişken,
global bir değişken olabilir.
Hiçbir sakınca yok,
arkadaşlar.
volt,
punk,
void.
p değişkeni,
fonksiyonun içinde tanımlandığı için,
otomatik ömürlü bir pointer değişken.
ama,
ismi DSP olan değişken,
parti ismi gibi oldu ama,
statik anahtar sözcüğüyle tanımlandığı için,
yerel bir değişken ama,
statik ömürlü yerel bir değişken.
gördüğünüz gibi bir pointer değişken,
global değişken olabiliyor.
Otomatik ömürlü bir yerel değişken olabiliyor.
Ya da statik ömürlü bir yerel değişken olabiliyor.
Ama durun durun bitmedi.
Peki,
şöyle bir değişken olsaydı,
bu değişkende fonksiyonun parametre değişkeni olan değişken olacaktı değil mi?
Kesinlikle.
Bakın hepsini tek bir kodda göstermiş olduk.
Bir anlam çıkartmaya çalışmayın.
Bir fonksiyonun parametre değişkeni olan pointer değişken,
yanına böyle yazayım,
parametre,
bu otomatik ömürlü bir yerel değişken,
bu statik ömürlü bir yerel değişken,
bu da arkadaşlar,
global bir değişken.
Ama,
bunlar pointer değişkenler.
Global pointer variable.
Anlaştık mı?
Epey oruçlu.
Evet.
Babaya selam Efe.
Şuraya kaydettim.
Evet.
Demek ki,
kısadan ise,
pointer değişkenler,
otomatik ömürlü,
statik ömürlü,
global değişken,
yerel değişken,
ya da fonksiyonun parametre değişkeni,
olabiliyormuş.
Herhangi bir şekilde burada bir engel yok.
Necati peki,
bir soru,
ömür açısından baktığımız zaman yine kurallar geçerli değil mi?
kesinlikle.
Yani bu şekilde tanımladığım değişken,
global değişken olduğu için statik ömürlü.
ama burada tanımladığım,
örneğin bir fonksiyon olsun,
main'de de aynı şey ama özellikle fonksiyonun içinde göstermek istiyorum.
Buradaki değişken fonksiyonun parametre değişkeni olduğu için otomatik ömürlü.
Buradaki değişken yine otomatik ömürlü,
yerel değişken.
Yani parametre otomatik ömürlü,
yerel değişken otomatik ömürlü.
Ama statik anahtar sözcüğüyle tanımlanan yerel değişken statik ömürlü
ve global değişkenler her zaman statik ömürlü.
yani ömür kavramıyla ilgili öğrendiğimiz bilgiler
pointer'larla geçerliliğini kaybetmiyorlar.
Anlaşıldı mı?
Peki, şimdi herkes çok dikkatli izliyor.
Yavaş yavaş zorlaşacak.
Arkadaşlar,
benimki değişkenimizin türü int.
Soru,
ben int türden bir değişkeni
a. Initialize etmeden tanımlayabilirim
b. Initialize ederek tanımlayabilirim.
Öyle değil mi?
Arkadaşlar,
initialize etmeden tanımladığım zaman
otomatik ömürlü değişkenlerin değeri ne?
Cevap garbage.
fakat statik ömürlü olsaydılar,
yani global ya da statik yerel değişken olsaydılar,
initialize etmesem dahi
bunlar zero initialize ediliyorlardı.
Değeri sıfır.
pointer'larla ilgili de durum böyle,
ama bir farklılık var ileride öğreneceğimiz.
Arkadaşlar, yine aynı koda geri dönelim.
Burada,
eğer bu pointer değişken,
otomatik ömürlü bir pointer değişken olsaydı,
yine hayata
garbage value,
indetermined value ile gelecekti.
ama statik ömürlü değişkenler,
burada,
ileride göreceğiz,
null pointer dediğimiz,
özel bir adres değeriyle hayata gelecekler.
Ama daha fazlasını şimdi bana sormayın,
null pointer,
çok daha sonra göreceğimiz bir kavram.
Anlaşıldı değil mi?
Statik ömürlü pointer değişkenlere ilk değer vermediğimiz zaman,
ileride öğreneceğimiz,
null pointer dediğimiz,
bir değerle, bir adresle hayata başlıyorlarmış.
bunda kayda geçmiş olalım.
Ama ileride tabi çok ayrıntılı göreceğiz.
Devam.
Şimdi geldik,
yavaş yavaş,
biraz daha önemli,
alt başlıklara.
Arkadaşlar,
değişkene ilk değer verebiliyorum dedim.
Doğal olarak,
türü int olan bir değişkene,
ilk değer verirken,
int türden bir değer,
initializer oluyor.
Adama yaparken de,
yine int türden bir ifadenin değerini atıyorum.
Zaten int türden bir ifadenin değerini atamazsam,
ya da int türden bir ifade ile değil de başka türden bir ifade ile initialize edersem,
tür dönüşümü gerçekleşecek.
Örtülü tür dönüşümü.
Peki pointer değişkenlerde durum nasıl?
Aynı.
Aynı derken kastettiğim şu,
p'nin değeri,
int nesne adresi olacak değil mi?
O zaman,
p'ye,
ilk değer verirken,
buraya dikkat,
hadi buna,
arkadaşlar,
sembolik olarak,
init,
eksip diyelim.
ee,
eşittirin sağ tarafındaki ifadenin türünün de,
yine int yıldız olmasını beklemeliyiz değil mi?
int türden nesne adresi tutacak bir değişkene,
int türden bir nesne adresi ile ilk değer vermem gerekiyor.
Atamada da öyle.
Bakınız,
buradaki yıldız,
değişkenimizin türünü anlatıyor.
Değişkeni atama yaparken,
tabii ki değişkenin ismini yazıyorum.
arkadaşlar,
p'ye eşit,
buraya,
int türden nesne adresi.
İlk değer verirken,
aynı şekilde,
ilk değer veren ifade,
int türden nesne adresi olacak.
Ama int türden nesne adresi olan bir ifade,
hangi görüntülerle karşımıza çıkar?
Onu da yavaş yavaş öğrenmeye başlayacağız.
Özetle,
pointer değişkenleri initialize edebilirim.
Pointer değişkenleri atama yapabilirim.
Arkadaşlar,
bunların değişken olduğunu unutmayalım.
Yani bu ne demek?
Mesela,
sadece sembolik olarak yazıyorum.
Burada,
diyelim ki,
x ve y isimli değişkenler var.
ben şimdi,
p değişkeninin değerini,
x değişkeninin adresi yapsam,
daha sonra,
atama deyimiyle,
hayır hayır,
p'nin değeri şimdi de,
y'nin adresi olsun diyebilir miyim?
Tabii ki.
Nasıl bir intürden değişkenin değerini,
10 iken 20 yapıyorsunuz,
20 iken,
57 yapabiliyorsunuz.
bir pointer değişkenin değerini de,
kodda,
farklı noktalarda değiştirebilirsiniz.
Ama,
sadece farklerde,
Uğur Ün,
Umut Yağmur,
Ece Bıçakçı,
gerek,
initialization,
da kullandığınız,
initializer,
expression,
yani ilk değerlerinin ifade,
gerek,
atama operatörünün,
sağ operanda olan ifadeler,
doğal olarak,
bir pointer değişken için kullanıldıklarından,
onların da adres olması gerekiyor.
Ha,
adres olmazsa ne olur?
Santax hatası olur mu,
olmaz mı?
Onlar,
ilerleyen saatlerin konusu.
Buraya kadar,
eğer,
anlattıklarımda,
yani,
burayı şu anda anlamanız gerekmiyor gibi,
saptamaların dışında bir sorun olmadıysa,
şimdi artık yavaş yavaş,
detaya gireceğiz.
ve ilerleyerek,
yol kat edeceğiz.
Arkadaşlar,
şimdiye kadar dikkat ederseniz,
şunlardan hiç bahsetmedim.
İyi de,
Necati,
pointer ne işe yarıyor?
Neden pointer değişken kullanıyorum?
Bunun amacı ne?
Ve bana ne fayda sağlayacaklar?
Bunları daha konuşmadık,
konuşacağız,
biraz daha yolumuz var oraya.
Sadece pointer değişkenlerin tanımlanmasından bahsettik.
Efendim,
bir iki tane önemli,
sentaks kurulundan bahsettik.
Biraz daha ilerlememiz,
pointer'larla ilgili,
dilin operatörlerini tanımamızla gerçekleşecek.
Öyle operatörler var ki,
zaten operatörler dersinde de,
ben buna değmiştim,
buraya bir gönderme yapmıştım.
bu operatörlerin oluşturduğu gruba,
böyle bir gruplama yaparsak,
pointer operatörleri deniyor.
Çünkü bu operatörler bir şekilde,
adreslerle ilgiler.
O,
bizim kursun başlarında,
oluşturduğumuz,
Necati'nin,
operatör öncelik tablosu vardı.
Şimdi o tabloya geri dönelim.
Sadece,
imleci takip etmeye çalışın.
Arkadaşlar,
bakın,
bakın.
Buradaki operatör,
adres operatörü,
bir pointer operatörü.
Yine,
buradaki operatör,
bir pointer operatörü.
Buradaki operatör,
O zaman,
pointerlarla ilgili,
aslında dilin,
dört tane,
ilerleyen dakikalarda demeyeyim ama,
farklı farklı derslerde öğreneceğimiz,
dört tane operatör var.
Önce bunların hepsini bir listeleyelim.
Arkadaşlar,
birinci öncelik seviyesindeki,
buraya dikkat,
bu operatör,
bunun ismi,
subscript operatörü.
Bir pointer operatörü bu.
Aslında,
iki tane farklı isimle,
kendisine hitap edebilirsiniz.
Biri,
subscript operatörü,
diğeri,
index operatörü.
Bu bir pointer operatörü.
Yine,
birinci öncelik seviyesinde,
şöyle bir operatör olduğunu,
görüyorsunuz ya da gördünüz.
Bu operatörün ismi de,
member selection,
halk arasındaki ismi de,
arrow operatörü.
Bu da,
bir pointer operatörü.
İkinci öncelik seviyesindeki,
ampersan,
token'ı ile,
belirtilen operatör,
bir pointer operatörü,
ismi,
address operatörü.
Yine,
ikinci öncelik seviyesinde,
arkadaşlar,
asterisk,
token'ı ile,
temsil edilen operatörün ismi,
de-referencing operatörü.
Yani,
bizim toplamda,
dört tane,
önemli pointer operatörümüz var.
Tekrar söylersek,
bunların isimlerini,
subscript operatörü,
member selection,
arrow operatörü,
address of operatörü,
ve,
de-referencing operatörü.
Yalnız,
bir noktaya dikkat,
arkadaşlar.
Pointer için,
neden,
float ya da,
double türünden,
bir değişkene ihtiyaç oluyor?
Soru çok soyut,
biraz da erken.
Dolayısıyla,
isterseniz,
sorunun,
belki,
kendi içinde de,
mantıksal olarak,
bir problem olabilir.
Ama,
bunu doğal karşılıyorum.
Çünkü,
pointerlerle ilgili,
neredeyse daha,
hiçbir şey anlatmadım.
Anlaşıldı mı?
Ama,
sorunuza çok kısa,
bir cevap vermem gerekirse,
tabi o da,
başka soruları doğuracak,
Ali İhsan.
Şöyle diyeyim,
float türden,
bir değişkenin,
adresini,
bir değişkende tutmak isterseniz,
o zaman,
türü,
float yıldız olan,
bir değişken,
tanımlamalısınız.
Yani,
float türden,
bir değişkenin,
adresini,
tutacak,
bir değişkene,
ihtiyaç,
duyacağım.
Neden,
sonuç ilişkisi,
biraz daha farklı.
anlaşıldı değil mi?
Soruyu,
tam ters bir şekilde,
sormalıyız.
Neden float yıldız türünden,
bir değişkene ihtiyaç duyayım,
Ali İhsan?
Çünkü,
demek ki orada,
float türden,
bir nesnenin,
adresini,
bir değişkende,
tutmak istediğim için.
doğru soru ve doğru cevap bu,
ama biraz erken.
Evet.
Şimdi bakınız,
bir not daha.
Aslında ben,
operatörler konusunda,
bunu anlatmıştım.
Arkadaşlar,
tekrar şu,
operatör öncelik davlomuza,
geri dönelim.
Bakın,
bir asterisk,
burada var,
bir ampersan,
burada var.
Ama bunlar farklı operatörler,
değil mi?
Daha önce konuşmuştuk.
Peki,
bunlar ne aslında?
Hadi oraya da,
bir yine gönderme yapalım,
kursun başında konuşmuş olsak da.
Arkadaşlar,
bakınız,
buradaki,
ampersan,
unary prefix bir operatör,
bu adres of operatörü.
Ama bir de,
aynı token'ın,
bitwise and,
dediğimiz,
bir operatörü temsil etme durum var.
Ama orada,
binary operatör.
Aradaki farkı görüyor musunuz?
Bu,
binary infix,
yani,
iki operant alan,
ara hep konumunda,
bu operatörün,
İngilizce'deki ismi,
bitwise and.
Ama bu,
ayrı bir operatör,
adres of operatör.
Yine aynı şekilde,
buradaki operatör,
görüyorsunuz,
yine,
unary prefix,
bu,
bir referansin operatörü,
fakat,
arkadaşlar,
buradaki operatör,
hepiniz biliyorsunuz,
multiplication,
yani,
çarkma operatörü.
yine tablomuza geri dönelim,
tabloda,
şöyle bir,
gözünüze kestirin,
bu bir pointer operatörü mü?
Evet,
address of operatörü,
bu bir pointer operatörü mü?
Evet,
dereferancing operatörü,
ama bu,
bitwise and operatörü,
ve bu,
multiplication operatörü,
yani,
token aynı,
ama buradaki token farklı bir operatöre,
buradaki asterisk token'ı farklı bir operatöre ilişkin.
Anlaşıldı mı?
Hangi operatörü olduğu,
binary operatör ya da unary operatör olarak kullanıldığına bağlı biçimde değişiyor diyebiliriz.
Süper.
Şimdi o zaman,
arkadaşlar,
geri dönelim,
ve,
dört tane pointer operatörümüz olduğunu söyledik.
Şimdi de şu soruya cevap vermeye çalışalım.
Bakalım,
hepinizden cevap bekliyorum.
Soru bir,
bu operatörü biz şimdiye kadar kullandık mı?
Evet ya da hayır.
Cevap,
evet,
hem de daha dün,
diziler konusunda,
Fatih'i,
Umut Yağmur,
Uğur'un,
Bravo,
diziler konusunda,
dizinin elemanına erişmek için kullandığımız operatör,
bu operatörün ta kendisi.
Yani,
dizinin elemanına erişme ifadesi de bir pointer operatörüyle gerçekleştiriliyor.
Dolayısıyla biz,
dizinin elemanına erişmek için,
örneğin bu şekilde bir ifade yazdığımızda,
aslında,
az önce bahsettiğim arkadaşlar,
pointer operatörü olan,
subscript operatörünü kullanmış oluyoruz.
Demek ki onlarca yüzlerce kez kullandık.
Peki,
devam ediyoruz.
Bu operatörü kullandık mı?
ooooh,
çok,
scanf çağrılarını hatırlayın.
Arkadaşlar,
daha pointerler konusuna hiç girmeden,
call by value,
call by reference konusunu anlattım.
ve,
şimdiye kadar yazdığımız test kodlarında,
onlarca diyebileceğimiz miktarda,
kes,
ne yaptık?
Scanf fonksiyonuna çağrı yaptık.
Dikkat ederseniz,
dikkat ettiyseniz,
bazen açıklama da yaptım.
Scanf fonksiyonuna yaptığım çağrılarda,
ben,
scanf fonksiyonuna adres olarak,
arkadaşlar,
aslında böyle bir ifade gönderdim.
Yani,
scanf fonksiyonuna argüman olarak gönderdiğim ifadelerin hepsinde olmasa da,
çoğunda ne vardı?
Bu operatörle oluşturulmuş bir ifade vardı.
Bu da şu demek,
demek ki biz,
aslında,
indeks operatörünü,
subscript operatörünü,
dizilerle ilgili sentaksı öğrenirken,
biraz ezbere de olsa,
onun pointer operatörü olduğunu,
açıkça söylemesek de,
kullandık.
Adres operatörünü de,
kursun başından beri,
özellikle scanf fonksiyonuna yaptığımız çağrılarda,
defalarca,
ne yaptık arkadaşlar?
Kullandık.
Ama,
doğrusu isterseniz,
kullanmadığımız iki tane pointer operatörü var.
Biri,
birkaç terste belki,
buraya takılmayın diyerek kullanmış olabilirim.
İşte,
ikinci öncelik seviyesindeki,
dereferencing operatörü,
bir de,
birinci öncelik seviyesindeki,
member selection,
arrow operatörü.
Yani pointer operatörlerinden,
iki tanesine,
biz zaten görsel olarak,
scanf çağrılarından,
ya da dizilerle ilgili işlemlerden,
aşinayız,
diyebiliriz.
Peki,
şimdi biraz daha ilerleyebilmek için,
ilk pointer operatörü olarak,
adres operatörünü,
mercek altına alacağız.
sadece adres operatörüyle ilgili,
temel bilgileri edinmemiz bile,
bizi bir hayli ileriye taşıyacak.
Hemen o zaman,
başlığımızı atalım.
Adres of operator.
Adres operatörü.
Arkadaşlar,
bu operatör,
operatörlerle ilgili terminolojiyi,
unutmuş olamayız değil mi?
Yöniri,
prefiks,
bir operatör,
bizim oluşturduğumuz tabloda,
ikinci öncelik seviyesinde,
ve defalarca konuştuk ama,
pointerler konusunda,
çok daha önemli hale gelecek,
ikinci öncelik seviyesinin,
öncelik yönü,
yani İngilizcesiyle,
associativity'si,
sağdan sola.
Biz sağdan sola diyoruz,
İngilizce'de nasıl söyleniyor?
Right associative.
Yani bu ne demek?
İkinci öncelik seviyesinde,
aynı ifade içinde,
ikinci öncelik seviyesinde,
birden fazla operatör varsa,
daha sağdakinin ürettiği değer,
daha soldakinin operandı olacak,
demek değil mi?
Evet.
Devam.
Arkadaşlar,
adres operatörünün,
kullanımında,
İngilizcesiyle,
önemli bir,
constraint var.
Constraint ne demekti?
Yani,
compile time'de,
kontrol edilen,
sağlanması gereken,
bir koşul var.
Operant,
L-value expression olmak zorunda.
Zaten,
L-value,
R-value testini de böyle yapmıştık,
değil mi?
Mesela,
şöyle bir kod yazsaydım,
lütfen dikkat,
arkadaşlar,
adres,
5,
bu kodun,
sentax hatası olmasının,
nedeni,
bu ifadenin,
sentax hatası oluşturmasının,
nedeni sorulsaydı,
ne demeliydiniz?
Uğur Ün,
Ozan Bektaş,
address of operator'ın,
operandı,
R-value expression olduğu için,
operand R-value,
bravo Uğur Bakınar,
kesinlikle.
Bezer şekilde,
adres,
öncelik parantezi,
x artı 5,
yine sentax hatası olmasının,
nedeni aynı,
adres operatörünün,
operandı olan ifade,
x artı 5 ifadesi,
ve dilimizin kurallarına göre,
R-value expression.
Ama bakın,
soru,
iki soruya dikkat,
adres x,
bu ifadede,
herhangi bir şekilde,
bir sentax hatası var mı?
Hayır,
çünkü operand,
L-value expression.
Burada no problem.
Soruya cevap vermeye çalışın.
Bu soru önemli.
Soru.
Bu ifadede kaç tane operatör var?
cevap 2.
Adres of operatörü,
subscript operatörü.
Hangi operatör daha yüksek önceliğe sahip?
Cevap tabii ki,
subscript operatörü.
Bravo.
yani,
böyle yazmakla,
Musa,
dalan çıkar,
böyle yazmakla,
sanki burada öncelik parantezi varmış gibi,
öncelik parantezi koymak arasında,
anlamsal açıdan bir fark var mı?
yok.
Bravo.
Dolayısıyla öncelik parantezine gerek de yok.
Peki bu ifadenin geçerli olması için bunun L-value expression olması gerekir değil mi?
Evet.
Peki bu L-value expression mı?
Yani A köşeli parantez 2 L-value expression mı?
Evet.
O zaman burada da bir syntax hatası yok.
Şimdi buraya kadar sadece neden bahsetmiş oldum?
İndeks operatörü ya da subscript operatörü diye bilinen bir operatörün,
operandanın L-value expression olması gerekiyor.
Eğer L-value expression değil de R-value expression ise,
arkadaşlar,
syntax hatası oluşuyor.
Şimdi soruyu aslında ben size tersten sormuştum kursun başında.
Hatırlarsanız kursun ilk konularından biri temel terimlerdi.
Ben temel terimleri, temel terminolojiyi anlatırken,
ifadelerin önemli niteliği olan L-value expression,
R-value expression kategorizasyondan bahsetmiştim.
Dilin kurallarına göre her ifadenin bir value kategorisi olduğunu,
yani bir ifadenin C'de bu açıdan iki kategoriden birine ilişkin olması gerektiğini söylemiştim.
Ya L-value ya R-value.
Tabii artık hangi ifadelerin L-value, hangi ifadelerin R-value olduğu konusunda yüksek bir algı elde ettiğiniz,
bazı belki bilmediğiniz noktalar olabilir.
Ama orada ben bir şey söylemiştim, hatırlıyor musunuz?
Demiştim ki size, belki hatırlayan arkadaşlarım olacaktır.
Bir ifadenin value kategorisinin,
yani L-value mu, R-value mu olduğunu unutursanız,
ya da şüpheniz varsa,
o ifadeyi adres operatörünün operanda yapın demiştim.
Eğer adres operatörünün operanda olması durumunda bir sentaks hatası oluşursa,
ifade R-value'dür.
Arkadaşlar, bravo, sentaks hatası oluşmazsa L-value'dür.
Mesela, bakalım kaç kişi hatırlıyor.
Artı X ifadesi L-value mu, R-value mu?
Cevap R-value.
Bunu nasıl kanıtladım?
Bu ifadeyi adres operatörünün operanda yaptığımda,
sentaks hatası oldu ve derleyici,
bakın bakın,
ampersan requires L-value biçiminde,
error mesajı verdi bize.
Yani adres operatörünün operandının L-value olması gerektiğini söylemesi demek,
aynı zamanda bu ifadenin R-value expression olması demek.
anlaşıldı mı?
Evet.
Tamam.
O zaman adres operatörünün operandı L-value expression olmak zorunda.
Şimdi devam edelim.
Peki diyelim ki adres operatörüyle oluşturulan bir ifade,
geçerli bir ifade.
Bu ifadenin türü ne?
Arkadaşlar, son derece basit.
Adres operatörü operanda olan nesnenin adresini değer olarak üretiyor.
Dolayısıyla adres operatörüyle oluşturulan ifadenin türü adres.
O zaman şimdi tekrar soruyorum.
Bu ifadenin türü ne?
Dokuzuncu satırdaki ifadenin türü ne?
Cevabınız ne olmalı?
Int yıldız.
Mesela bu değişkenimiz int türden olmasaydı,
short türden olsaydı,
bu ifadenin türü ne olacaktı?
Short yıldız olacaktı.
Yani pointer to short olacaktı.
Anlaşıldı mı?
İşte C dilinde adres türünden olan ifadeler farklı görüntülerle karşımıza çıkacak dedik.
Ama en sık karşımıza çıkan biçimlerden biri,
adres operatörüyle oluşturulmuş bir ifade.
Arkadaşlar o zaman bir pointer değişkene ilk değer verebilecek
ya da bir pointer değişkene atanabilecek ifadeler de bulmuş oluyoruz.
Mesela şu koda bakın.
Int yıldız.
P.T.L.
Eşittir adresiyiz.
Arkadaşlar lütfen çok dikkatli izleyin.
Uygar daha sonra cevap vereyim mi?
Şimdi arkadaşların kafası karışmasın.
Önce burayı bitirelim ama mutlaka cevap vereceğim.
Merak etmeyin.
İlerleyen dakikalarda diyelim.
Arkadaşlar çok dikkatli izleyin.
Bu bir atama mı?
Assignment mı?
Yoksa initialization mı?
Cevap tabii ki initialization.
Assignment değil.
O zaman bakın.
Kendisine ilk değer verdiğim değişken PTR.
Bu da ona ilk değer veren ifade.
Böylece PTR değişkenini kimin adresiyle başlatıyorum?
X değişkeninin adresiyle hayata başlatıyorum.
O zaman bakın.
Değişkenimin türü int yıldız.
Ona ilk değer veren ifadenin türü de int yıldız.
Devam edelim.
Peki bu bir atama mı?
Yoksa initialization mı?
Bu ise tabii ki bir assignment.
Çünkü ortada bir bildirim yok.
Ama her ikisinin ortak noktası ne?
Burada ilk değer veren ifadenin türü int yıldız.
Yani int nesne adresi türü.
Burada da PTR değişkenime atanan ifadenin türü yine int yıldız.
Buradan şöyle bir sonucu da çıkarmalıyız değil mi?
Bir pointer değişkeni atama ya da ilk değer vermede kullanacağımız en tipik ifadelerden biri
bir değişkenin aynı türden yani ona uygun türden değişkenin adres operatörüyle elde edilmiş adresi.
Arkadaşlar bazen görüntü kafanızı karıştırabilir.
Mesela bakınız int x eşittir 5, yıldız P eşittir adres x.
Burada bir hata, bir yanlışlık, bir kusur var mı?
Çevap.
Hayır.
Böyle yazmak neye eşit değer?
Aslında iki tane değişken tanımlıyorum.
int x eşittir 5, int yıldız P eşittir x'in adresi.
Musa anlaşıldı değil mi?
Diğer arkadaşlarım tabi sadece Musa beye sormuyorum.
Ece Bıçakçı anlaşıldı mı?
Peki devam edelim şimdi.
Sizce şu kodda bir kusuru var mı?
int x eşittir 5, int yıldız P1 eşittir adres x,
int yıldız P2 eşittir P1.
Burada bir problem var mı?
Cevap.
Hiçbir problem yok.
Arkadaşlar P2 değişkenine P1 değişkeninin değeriyle ink değer veriyorsunuz.
Bunların türü aynı olduğuna göre bir problem yok.
Anlaşıldı değil mi?
P2'nin değeri P1'in değeri olsun.
Peki söyleyin bakalım.
Bundan sonra P2 bu noktada P2'nin değeri x'in adresi diyebilir miyiz?
A evet veya hayır.
Cevap tabi ki P1'in değeri x'in adresi olduğuna göre P2'ye de P1'in değeriyle ilk değer verdiğime göre hem P1 hem P2 her ikisinin değeri de x'in adresi.
Anlaşıldı mı?
Takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Peki hadi bakalım şimdi zor bir soru.
7. Herkes deniyor.
7. 8. 9. satırdaki bildirimler 3 ayrı declaration statement yerine tek bir declaration statementta comma separated listle bunu bildirin.
10 saniye bekleyeceğim.
Siz de cevabınızın doğru ya da yanlış olduğuna bakınız.
Evet.
O zaman cevap geliyor.
19. 8. 7. 6. 5. 4. 3. 2. 1. 0.
Eğer şöyle yazdıysanız doğru.
Int x'i aynı sırayla yazıyorum.
Int x eşittir 5 virgül yıldız P1 eşittir x'in adresi virgül yıldız P2 eşittir P1.
Eğer böyle yazdıysanız ki Uğur böyle yazmış diğer arkadaşlarım Uygar böyle yazmış hiçbir ata yok.
Tabi bu yıldız bitişik yazılmış ayrı yazılmış o tamamen kullandığınız yazım biçimiyle ilgili.
Anlaştık mı?
Arkadaşlar böylece bakınız bir pointer değişkene atanabilecek ya da ilk değer olarak verilebilecek iki tane önemli ifadeyi ortaya çıkarttık bile.
Nedir?
Eğer PTR bir pointer değişkense A ona uygun türden bir değişkenin adres operatörüyle elde edilmiş adresini atayabilirim ya da ilk değer verebilirim.
Ama bir başka yolda ne olabilir?
Kendi türünden bir değişkenin değeri.
Yani P ile PTR aynı türden değişkenlerse tıpkı I1 ve I2 ikisi de int türden değişken olsun I1 eşittir I2 yazmam ne kadar doğalsa I1 eşittir I2 yazarak I2'nin değerini I1'e atıyor isem aynı şekilde diyelim ki P1 ve P2 de aynı türden pointer değişkenlerse bunların değerlerini birbirine ne yapabilirim?
Atayabilirim.
Takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Evet.
Arkadaşlar çok dikkatli izleyin.
Şimdi pointer değişkenlere ilginç bir şekilde atayabileceğimiz ya da ilk değer olarak verebileceğimiz bir ifade daha var.
Aslında bunu az da olsa konuşmuştuk.
Arkadaşlar bu bir dizi.
Int A diyelim ki 5.
Dize ilk değer vereyim.
Ne demiştim size?
Bir iki istisna hariç.
O istisnaları daha sonra öğreneceğiz demiştim.
Bir dizinin ismi bir ifade içinde kullanıldığında
Array Decay ya da Array to Pointer Conversion denilen bir kuralı uygulanıyor.
C ve C++ dillerinin diğer dillerden epey farklı bir kuralı.
Neydi Array Decay ya da Array to Pointer Conversion?
Dizi isminin, dizinin ilk elemanının adresine dönüştürülmesi.
İnt Yıldız P eşittir A.
Öğrenmeye yeni başlayanları kapısını karıştıran durumlardan biri ya da şuraya bakın P eşittir B.
İlk başta öğrenci özellikle kendi kendine öğrenmeye çalıştığında biraz şaşırıyor.
Diyor ki Allah Allah pointer değişkeni dizi atanmış.
Aslında pointer değişkeni dizi atanmıyor ya da pointer değişkeni diziyle ihtiyar vermiyoruz.
Burada Array Decay denilen kural uygulanıyor.
Yani A ifadesi A dizinin ilk elemanının adresine dönüştürülüyor.
Yine 12. satırda
Atama operatörünün sağ operanda olan ifadedeki B ismi
Array Decay kuralı gereği
B dizinin ilk elemanının adresine dönüştürülüyor.
Yani böyle yazmakla
Ne yazmak arasında bir fark yok?
A köşeli parantez sıfırın adresi.
Yine böyle yazmakla
B köşeli parantez sıfırın
Adres operatörü ile elde edilmiş adresi yazmak arasında
Anlamsal açıdan bir fark yok.
Dolayısıyla pointerlara atanabilecek ya da ilk değer olarak verilebilecek
Üçüncü ifademizle de tanışmış oldu.
Bakın hepsi sık sık karşınıza çıkacak.
Adres operatörü ile elde edilmiş bir
İfade
Dolayısıyla bir adres
Arkadaşlar
Bir başka pointer değişkenin değeri
Ya da
Pointer'ın
Göstereceği, pointer'ın
Tutacağı adres türünden
Elemanlara sahip bir dizinin
İsmi
Bunlar en sık karşımıza çıkan
Pointer değişkene
Ya da değişkenlere
İlk değer olarak verebileceğimiz
Ya da atayabileceğimiz
İfadeler
Şimdi burada
Biraz erken de olsa
Önemli sorulardan biri
Peki pointer değişkene
Bunların dışında bir ifade
Atarsak ne olur?
Arkadaşlar
Benim sevdiğim şöyle bir söz var
Daha çok C ve C++ ile ilgili
Şöyle diyorlar
Daha önce belki söyledim
Belki söylemedim
Legality
Is not
Morality
Yani
Biri bir Türkçe'ye çevirirsek
Legal olması
Bir şeyin legal olması
Onun ahlaki doğru olduğu
Anlamına gelmiyor
Yani legal olan
Ama eleştirecek
Yanlış olarak değerlendirilecek
Nasıl gerçek hayatta
Birçok durum varsa
Arkadaşlar
Burada da
C ve C++
Dillerinde de böyle durumlar
Çok özellikle
C dilinde
Dolayısıyla
Yazdığınız bir kodun
Legal olması
Başka
Yani dilin
Sentaks kurallarına
Uygun olması
Başka
O kodun doğru
Problemsiz
Üretimde
Kullanılabilir
İyi bir kod
Olması
Başka
Mesela
Ben şöyle bir kod yazsam
Int x eşittir
Int y eşittir
x eşit
Eşit y
Legalite açısından
Hiçbir problem yok
Ama normal bir ruh sağlığı içinde
Böyle bir
Deyim yazmak
İstememin
Hiçbir açıklaması
Olamaz
Yani bu kod
Legal
Ama doğru bir kod
Değil
Yani bunu bir örnek
Olarak veriyorum
İşte pointerlarla
İlgili kodlarda da
Legality is not morality
Çok sık karşımıza çıkıyor
Ve burada
C dileğiyle
C++
Dilinin
Sentaks
Kuralları açısından da
Farklılık var
C++
Farklı türlerden
Dönüşümlerin
Bir kısmına
İzin vermiyor
Onları
Illegal olarak
Saptıyor
Ama C dilinde
Legal ama
Yanlış
Diyebiliyoruz
Hadi bu durumları
Tek tek inceleyelim
Bir
Arkadaşlar
Diyelim ki
Double türden
Bir de
Ya da
Int türden bir pointer değişkenim var
Int yıldız P
Int yıldız türden
Arkadaşlar
Bir de int türden değişkenim var
Bakın şöyle yazmamda
Bir sorun yok
Çünkü
Atama operatörünün
Sol operanda olan
Nesnenin türüyle
Atama operatörünün
Sağ operanda olan
İfadenin türü aynı
Ama böyle yazmak yerine
Bilerek ya da bilmeyerek
Şöyle yazarsak
Bu legal mi sorusunun
Cevabı ayrı
Bunu yazmak
Doğru bir şey mi
O ayrı
Legalite açısından
Durum şöyle
C'de legal
C artı artı da
İllegal
Yani
C plus plus dilinde
Bir pointer değişkene
Adres olmayan
Bir veriyi atamak
Örneğin
Bir tam sayı
Gerçek sayı
Değeri gibi
İllegal zaten
Fakat
C dilinde
İllegal değil
Örtülü tür dönüşümü var
Arkadaşlar
P'nin türüne ne demiştik
Cevap
Int yıldız
Peki bu ifadenin türüne
Int
İşte C dilinde
Burada
Int türünden
Int yıldız türüne
Örtülü dönüşüm olacak
Bu da
Bu kodun yanlışlıkla
Yazıldığı anlamına
Gelecek
Çünkü bunu bilerek
İsteyerek
Yazma ihtimalim yok
Bilerek
İsteyerek
Yazsaydım
Zaten
İleride öğreneceğimiz
Biçimde
Tür dönüştürme
Operatörünü
Kullanırdım
Ben şöyle yazsam
Niyetimi belli etmiş olurum
Ama böyle yazmanın
Hiçbir şekilde
Karşılığı yok
Ama kod legal
Özetle
Bir pointer
Değişkene
Buraya dikkat
Adresi olmayan
Bir veriyi
Atamayın
İlk değer olarak
Vermeyin
Verirseniz
C++
Dilinde kod
Yazıyorsanız
Error olur
Geçersiz bir kodtur
C dilinde
Yazıyorsanız
Kodu
Legaldir ama
Yanlış kabul edilir
C dilinde bunu
Bilerek isteyerek
Yazıyorsanız
O zaman da
Niyetinizi anlatmak için
Daha sonradan
Göreceğimiz üzere
Typecast
Operatörünü
Tür dönüştürme
Kullanmalısınız
Anlaştık mı?
Tamam
O zaman
Pointer
Değişkene
Örneğin
Tam sayı
Gerçek sayı
Ataması
Yapmıyoruz
Bu bir
Ama yaparsak
C de
Legal
Verlik
Necat
Tamam
C de
Legal
Ama derleyici
Uyarı
Mesajı
Verir mi?
Verir
Anakım
Derleyicilerin
Hepsi
Arkadaşlar
Durumu
Şüpheli
Karşılayarak
Bakın
Benim derleyicimin
Verdiği
Hata
Mesajına
Özür dilerim
Uyarı
Mesajına
Bir de
Dosyanın
Uzantısını
Bir kez
Sadece
Artık
Bundan sonra
Yapmayacağım
Cpp
Yaptığında
Arkadaşlar
Derliyorum
Bakın
Derleyici
Açık
Error
Can not convert
From int
To int
Yıldız
Bu hata
Mesajı çok açık
Değil mi?
Bakın ne diyor?
Convert ne demek?
Dönüştürmek
Can not convert
Dönüştürmez
Dönüştürülemez
From int
Int'den
To
Neye?
Int yıldızı
Yani diyor ki
Bu konunun legal olması için
Int türünden
Int yıldız türüne
Implicit
Örtülü
Yani
Conversion olması gerekir
Ama böyle bir dönüşüm olmadığı için
Legal değil diyor
Burada doğrusu isterseniz
C++
Tabii çok daha koruyucu
C diliyle
C++
Dili arasında
Kategorik farklılıklardan biri de
C++
Eğitiminde de
Bunu çok sık tekrar edeceğim
C++
Daki
Tür kontrolünün
Çok daha katı
İngilizcesiyle
Strict olması
Yani
C'de
Legal olan
Ama yanlış olan
Dönüşümler var
En iyi ihtimalle
Derleyiciden
Az önce gösterdiğim gibi
Bir
Uyarı mesajı
Bekleyebilirsiniz
Ama
Aynı dönüşümler
C++
Da geçerli değil
Daha koruyucu
Bu açıdan
Baktığımız zaman
Peki
Devam
Peki şu durumda ne olur
İzleyin
Arkadaşlar
Double
Deval
Eşittir
4.5
Dosyanın uzantısını
Tekrar
C yapalım
Ya da
Önce
C++
Yapalım
Denemek
Daha kolay olsun
P eşittir
Adres
D var
Arkadaşlar
Şimdi sadece
Soruma cevap verin
Atama operatörünün
Sağ operanda olan
İfadenin
Türü ne
Atama operatörünün
Sağ operanda olan
İfadenin
Türü ne
Double değil
Yapmayın
Double yıldız
Bakın şöyle olsaydı
Double olurdu
Musa doğru mu
Ama
Bu ifadenin
Türü
Double yıldız
Adres çünkü
Peki bu durum
Atama operatörünün
Sol operanda olan
İfadenin
Türü ne
Cevap
Int yıldız
O zaman bu kodun
Legal olması için
Double yıldız
Türünden
Int yıldız
Türüne
Implicit
Conversion
Olması
Gerekir
Değil mi
Ama gördüğünüz gibi
Bakın
C++
Derleyicisi
Diyor ki
Yazsak
Hemşerim
Can not
Convert from
Double star
To int star
Double yıldız
Türünden
Int yıldız
Türüne
Dönüşüm
Yok diyor
Ama maalesef
Keşke
C++
Olduğu gibi
Olsaydı
Kontrol
Zorunluluğu
O kadar
Katı olmayan
C dilinde
Bu kod
Legal
Ama bunun
Legal olması
C'de
Legal
Ama
Yanlış
Doğru olduğu
Anlamına
Gelmiyor
Yine
Ana akım
Derleyicilerin
Hemen hepsi
Bir
Sentaks
Hatası
Olmasa
Yanlışlıkla
Yazıldığını
Düşünerek
Size
Uyarı
Mesajı
Verecek
Böyle bir
Garanti
Veremiyorum ama
Uyarı
Mesajı
Vermeyen
Derleyici
Bulmakta
Zor
Olur
Bakın
Yine
Derleyici
Arkadaşlar
Bir daha
Derleyelim
Şuradan
Kopyalayalım
Okuyalım
Önce
Warning
Ne diyor
Incompatible
Yani
Uyumsuz
Types
From
Double
Star
To
Int
Star
Yani
Double
Star
Yıldız
Türünden
Int
Yıldız
Türüne
Örtülü
Dönüşüm
Oluyor
Diyor
Ama
Legal
C++
Yine
Onu da
Yazalım
İsterseniz
Sentaks
Hatası
Otanlara
Vermeden
Şuraya
Kadar
Geldim
Bir
Pointer
Değişkene
A
Bir
Tam
Sayı
Gerçek
Atayabiliriz
Ama
Bu
Yanlış
Kabul
Ediliyor
Neden
Yanlış
Onu
Öğreneceğiz
Ama
Küçük
Bir
İhtimalle
Olsa
Bilerek
İsteyerek
Bir
Pointer
Değişkene
Örneğin
Bir
Tam
Sayı
Değer
Atıyorsanız
Onu
Tür
Dönüştürme
Operatörü
Yapmalısınız
İki
Bir
Pointer
Değişkene
Farklı
Türden
Bir
Adres
Atamak
Yani
Int
Nesne
Adresi
Tutmaya
Yönelik
Bir
Pointer
Değişkene
Örneğin
Double
Türden
Bir
Nesne
Adresi
Atamak
C++
Error
Biraz
Daha
Teknik
İfade
C++
Dilinde
Farklı
Adres
Türleri
Arasında
Örtülü
Tür
Dönüşümü
Yok
Ama
C dilinde
Var
Dolayısıyla
Derleyiciniz
Size
C'de
Yazdığınız
Kodlarda
Adresler
Arasında
Bir
Uyumsuzluk
Ya
Pointer
Atanan
İfadeyle
Pointer
Kendi
Türü
Arasında
Bir
Uyumsuzluk
Olduğu
Uyarısını
Verirse
Yanlış
Bir
Şey
Yapıyorsunuzdur
Oraya
Bakın
Nereyi
Yanlış
Anladığınızı
Anlamaya
Çalışın
Şimdi
Bir
Soru
Daha
Geliyor
Biz
Yine
Adres
Operatörüne
Geri
Dönelim
Ve
Bir
Soru
Daha
Soralım
Bakalım
Tahmin
Edebilecek
Misiniz
Sizce
Bunu Daha
Söylemedim
Ama
Tahmin
Etmenizi
Bekliyorum
Doğru
Ya
Yanlış
Bir
Tahminde
Bulun
Bu
Da
Bir
İfade
Olduğuna
Göre
Bu
İfadenin
De
Bir
Value
Kategorisi
Var
Değil
Yani
Bu
İfade
L
Value
Ya
Ar
Value
Peki
Söyleyin
Bakalım
Tahmin
Edin
Bu
İfade
L
Value
Mu
Ar
Value
Mu
Cevap
Kesinlikle
Ar
Value
Ozan
Bunu
Hiç
Unutmamak
Üzere
Kafamızın
Bir
Yerine
Yazıyoruz
Adres
Operatörü
İle
Oluşturulan
İfadeler
Ar
Value
Expression
Arkadaşlar
Bakın
Ben
Atama
Operatörünün
Sol
Operandayı
Yapmak
İstesem
Bir
Şey
Dikkatinizi
Çekiyor
Ama
Daha
Şimdiden
Sentaks
Hatası
Olduğunu
Söylüyor
Eşittir
Sağına
Ne
Yazdığınızla
İlgili
Değil
Umut
Yağmur
Neden
Sentaks
Hatası
Çünkü
Buraya
Ne
Yazdığımla
Alakalı
Değil
Atama
Operatörünün
Sol
Operanda
Olan
İfadenin
L
Value
Expression
Olması
Gerekiyor
Takip
Edebiliyor
Musunuz
Oysa
Bu
L
Value
Expression
Değil
R
Value
Expression
Anlaşıldı
mı
Herkes
Anladı
mı
Dolayısıyla
Adres
Operatörü
İle
Oluşturulan
İfadeler
R
Value
Expression
Mesela
Şöyle bir soru
Sorsaydım size
Dokuzuncu
Satırdaki
İfadede
Sentaks
Hatası
Bekler
Misiniz
Beklemez
Cevap
Tabi ki
Sentaks
Hatası
Neden
Bakın
Sentaks
Hatası
Burada
Yok
Bu
Doğal
Burada
Adres
Operatörünün
Operandı
XL
Value
Expression
Ama
Buradaki
Adres
Operatörünün
Operandı
Bu
İfade
L
Value
Expression
Değil
Demin
Söyledik
Yani
Burada
Sentaks
Hatası
Olması
Sonucunu
Doğuran
Daha
Soldaki
Adres
Operatörünün
Operandının
L
Value
Expression
Olmaması
Anlaşıldı
mı
Bunu
Neden
Söylüyorum
Çünkü
Bazı
Yani
Kursta
Değil de
Böyle
Kendi
Orada
Buradan
Öğrenenler
Ya da
Öğrenmeye
Çalışanlar
Böyle
Soru
Soruyorlar
Necati
X'in
Adresinin
Adresini
Almak
İstiyorum
Derleyici
Sentaks
Hatası
Veriyor
Ne
Demekse
Kendisi
Böyle
Bir
Kavram
İcat
Etmiş
Ne
X'in
Adresinin
Adresi
Ne
Demek istediğini
Anlamıyorum
Ama
O
Kafasında
Yanlış
Bir
Model
Oluşturmuş
Olmalı
Ya da
Diyor ki
Bakın
Bu daha
Pamik
Şöyle bir
Kod
Yazmış
Diyor ki
Necati
Sentaks
Hatası
Oluyor
Niye ki
Ne
Yapmak
İstiyorsun
Diyorum
İşte
X'in
Adresini
Değiştirmek
İstiyorum
Bu da
Böyle
Kafasında
Bir
Model
Oluşturmuş
Şimdi
Modelin
Neden
Yanlış
Anlatacağım
Ama
Sentaks
Hatası
Olmasının
Nedenini
Zaten
Anladınız
Değil mi
Ya kardeşim
Buraya
Ne
Yazdığından
Bağımsız
Olarak
Zaten
Bu
İfade
R
Value
Expression
Olduğu
İçin
Atama
Operatörünün
Sol
Operanda
Olması
Sentaks
Hatası
Yine
Burada
Kafanda
Ne
Kurduğundan
Bağımsız
Olarak
Adres
Operatörünün
Operanda
Dolan
İfade
R
Value
Expression
Olduğu
İçin
Sentaks
Hatası
Arkadaşlar
Ama
Kafada
Oluşturulan
Modeli
De
Tahmin
Ediyorum
Bakın
Şimdi
Ben
Aslında
Uzunca
Bir
Süre
Pointerler
Konusunu
Anlatırken
Şöyle
Anlatıyordum
Sonra
Vazgeçtim
Neden
Vazgeçtiğimi
De
Anlatayım
Nasıl
Diyordum
İnsanların
Biz
Adresleri
Var
Oturdukları
Yeri
Belirliyor
O
Mesela
Necati Ergin'in
Adresi
Tabo
O Zamanlar
İstanbul'daydım
Ben
Bu
Senenin
Başında
Eskişehir'e
Taşındım
Burada
Çok
Memnun
Eskişehir'den
Nasıl
Necati Ergin'in
Adresi
İşte
Eskişehir
Büyükdere
Mahallesi
Vesaire
İse
Değişkenlerin
De
Adresleri
Var
Necati Ergin'in
Adresi
Nerede
Oturduğu
Bilgisi
Nerede
İkamet
Ettiği
Bilgisi
Bir
Değişkenin
Adresi
Derken
De
Kast
Edilen
Değişkenin
Programın
Çalışma
Zamanındaki
Yeri
Değişkenler
Ve
Bellekte
Yer
Kaplıyor
Değil mi
İşte
Bu
Değişken
Nerede
Tutuluyor
Sorusunun
Cevabı
O
Değişkenin
Adresi
O
Değişken
Nerede
Oturuyor
Diyebiliriz
Necati
Nerede
Oturur
İkamet
Eder
Sorusunun
Cevabı
Necati
Adresi
İval
Nerede
Oturur
Rantaym'da
Yeri
Neresi
Sorusunun
Cevabı
İval
Adresi
Ama
Sonra
Neden
Bu
Analojide
Çok
Israr
Etmedim
Çünkü
Analojilerin
Çoğunda
Olduğu
Gibi
Abartırsanız
Analoji
Olmaktan
Çıkar
Gerçeği
Yansıtmaz
Ve
İnsanlarda
Analojiye
Hep
Bir
Tık
Arttırma
Eğilimi
Var
Şimdi
Analojiyi
Bir
Tık
Arttıralım
Necati
Ergin
Adresini
Söylemiştim
Peki
Necati
Bugün
Bu
Yıld
Eskişehir'de
Otururken
Başka
Bir
Şehre
Taşınabilir
Belki
Bir
Daha
Sene
Tekrar
İstanbul'a
Taşınacak
O
Zan
Necati'nin
Adresi
Değişecek
Böyle
Bir
Analoji
Kurunca
Programcıda
Böyle
Bir
Beklenti
Oluşturmuş
Oluyoruz
O
Da
Şöyle
Zannediyor
Değişkenlerin
De
Programın
Çalışma
Zamanında
Adresi
Değişebilir
Böyle
Değişkeni
Bellekte
Buradayken
Yeri
Değişip
X
Değişkeni
Başka
Bir
Yere
Taşınabilir
mi
Cevap
Hayır
Önce
Burayı
Çok
Anlamalıyız
Belki
Sizde
Yanlışlıkla
Okuduklarınızdan
Etkilenerek
Ya da
Kafanızda
Böyle
Olması
Gerektiğini
Düşünerek
Değişkenlerin
Adreslerinin
Programın
Çalışma
Zamanında
İstanbul'dan
Eskişehir'e
Taşınan
Necati'de
Olduğu
Gibi
Değişebileceğini
Düşünmüş
Olabilirsiniz
Hayır
Böyle
Bir
Şey
Yok
Böyle
Bir
Model
Yok
Hiçbir
Zaman
Bir
Değişkenin
Adresi
Değişmiyor
Yani
O
Yaşarken
Hayattayken
Yani
Runtime'da
Bir
Değişkenin
Yerden
Bir
Yere
Taşınması
Adresinin
Değişmesi
Ya da
Adresinin
Değiştirilmesi
Gibi
Bir
İşlem
Var
Hayır
Böyle
Beklentiyle
Pointerler
Konusunu
Öğrenmiş
Olabilirsiniz
Mesela
Programcı
Diyor ki
Ben
X'in
Yerini
Değiştireyim
X'in
Yerini
Değiştirmek
Ona
Göre
X'in
Adresini
Değiştirmek
Yani
Eğer
X'in
Adresini
Değiştirmeye
Yönelik
Bir
Kod
Yazarsa
Programın
Çalışma
Zamanında
X
Adeta
Oradan
Başka
Bir
Yere
Taşınacak
Böyle
Bir
Şey
Var
mı
Böyle
Bir
Şey
Kesinlikle
Yok
Ve
Tekrar
Sentaks
Düzeyine
Gelirsek
Son
Olarak
Adres
Operatörü
Oluşturulan
Bir
İfade
R
Value
Expression
Yalnız
Bir
İstesna
Var
Biraz
Karmış
Kadı
Onu
Da
Anlatayım
Ondan
Sonra
Ara
Verelim
Arkadaşlar
Bakın
Şimdi
Sadece
Soruya
Cevap
Örmeye
Çalışın
Çünkü
Burada
Muhtemelen
Ben
Anlatmadığım
İçin
Yanlış
Cevap
Vereceksiniz
Bu
İfade
L
Value
Expression
mı
R
Value
Expression
mı
Tahmin
Edin
Cevap
L
Value
Expression
Arkadaşlar
Değişken
İsimleri
Anlamında
Olan
Bütün
İfadeler
L
Value
Expression
Bakın
Eğer
L
Value
Expression
Olmasaydı
Adres
Operatörün
Operanda
Yaptığımda
Sentaks
Hatası
Olurdu
Gece
Öyle
Değil mi
Uygar
Öyle
Değil mi
Musa
Öyle
Değil mi
Ama
Bakın
Adres
Operatörün
Operandı
Yaptığımda
Herhangi
Bir
Şekilde
Ne
Olmadı
Sentaks
Hatası
Olmadı
Demek ki
İleride
Öğreneceğiz
Pekala
Bir
Dizi
İsmi
Adres
Operatörün
Operandı
Olabiliyormuş
Bunu
Bir
Kenara
Yazalım
Ama
Şimdi
İzleyin
Bakın
A
Eşittir
Dediğimde
Eşittir'in
Sana
Ne
Yazacağımdan
Bağımsız
Olarak
Sentaks
Hatası
Oluşuyor
Şimdi
Bu
İlginç
Bir
Durum
Yani
Hem
A'ya
L
Value
Expression
Diyebiliyoruz
Hem de
Atama
Operatörünün
Sol
Operandı
Olması
Sentaks
Hatası
O
Zaman
Sırf
Bu
Durum
Bile
Şu
Tanımı
Yüzde
Yüz
Doğru
Olmaktan
Alıkoyuyor
Şöyle
Diyebilir
Miyiz
Atama
Operatörünün
Sol
Operandı
Olabilen
İfadeler
L
Value
Expression
Diyemeyiz
Çünkü
Eğer
Öyle
Deseydik
A
L
Value
Expression
Olmasına
Rağmen
Atama
Operatörünün
Sol
Operandı
Olamıyor
Atama
Operatörünün
Sol Operandı
Olamamasının
Nedeni
Bravo
Ali
Cevabınız
Yüzde
Yüz
Doğru
Uygar
Zaten
Onu
Söylemiş
Array
Dikey
Arkadaşlar
Siz
Bir
İfade
İçinde
Kullandığınızda
Bunu
Derneğcinin
Gözüyle
Bakarsak
Siz
Aslında
Bunu
Yazmış
Oluyorsunuz
Yani
Atama
Operatörününün
Sol Operandı
Olunca
Array
Dikey
Uygulanıyor
L-Value
Expression
Olan
A ifadesi
Array
Dikeyden
Dolayı
L-Value
Expression
Olma
Niteliğini
Kaybediyor
Yani
Biraz Daha
Teknik
Tabiriyle
L-Value
Bu
R-Value
Dönüşümü
Gerçekleşiyor
Neden
Sentaks
Ataks
Olduğunu
Anladınız
Mı
Kesinlikle
Bu
Nedenden
Dolayı
İşte
O
Yüzden
C dilinin
Standardı
Arkadaşlar
L-Value
Teriminin
Yanı sıra
Bir terim
Daha
Kullanıyor
L-Value
İki kategoriye
Ayırıyor
Bir
Modifiable
L-Value
İki
Arkadaşlar
Unmodifiable
Non-Modifiable
L-Value
Mesela
Bir Örnek
Arkadaşlar
A-L-Value
Evet
Ama
Non-Modifiable
L-Value
Yani
Adam
Operatörün
Sol Operanda
Olamaz
Ama
Adres Operatörün
Operanda
Olabilir
İleriye
Yönelik
Bir Örnek
Daha
Umuz
Salahtar
Sözcüyle
Nitelenen
Değişkenler
X-L-Value
Bu
İfade
L-Value
Cevap
Evet
Bakın
L-Value
Olmasaydı
Adres Operatörün
Operanda
Olması
Sentax
Hatası
Olurdu
Ama
Adam Operatörünün
Sol Operanda
Olsa
Sentax
Hatası
Oluşuyor
İşte
Bu İfadede
Yine
L-Value
Ama
Non-Modifiable
L-Value
Anlaşıldı mı?
Tamam
Şimdi
Bir
Soru
Daha
Ve Ondan
Sonra
Söz
Ara
Veriyorum
Çok
Dikkatli
Zeyn
Ben
Size
Bir
Dizinin
İsminin
Bir
İfade
İçinde
Kullanıldığında
Dizinin
İlk
Elemanının
Adresine
Dönüştürüldüğünü
Ve
Buradaki
Kurala
Array
Decay
Yani
Array'in
Çürümesi
Bozulması
Anlamında
Ya da
Array to
Pointer
Conversion
Dendiğini
Söylemiştim
Fakat
Bazı
İstisnalar
Olduğunu
Da
Söyledim
Şimdi
En
Önemli
İstisnayı
Görün
Çok
Kık
Atlezi
Int
A
Arkadaşlar
Söyleyin
Size
Of
Adres
A
Köşeli
Parantez
Sıfır
Bu ifadenin
Değeri
Ne
Bugünkü dersin
Başını
Hatırlayın
Bu ifade
Bravo
Neden
Çünkü
Size
Of
Operatörünün
Operanda
Bir ifade
Olduğunda
O ifadenin
İlişkin
Olduğu
Türün
Size
Of
Değerini
Öğretiyordu
Bu ifadenin
Türü
Ne
Int
Yıldız
Türünün
Size
Of
Değeri
Ne
Cevap
Benim
Derleyicim
De
Prim
Tev
Yüzde
Z
U
New
Line
Size
Of
A
Köşeli
Parantez
Sıfır
Peki şimdi
Alttaki
Print
Çağrısına
Bakalım
Burada da
Ereği
Dikey
Olsaydı
O zaman
9.
Satırdaki
Print
Ve
10.
Satırdaki
Print
Aynı
Değeri
Yazdırırdı
Değil mi?
Ama
Burada
Aynı
Değer
Yazdırılmıyor
Çünkü
Burada
Array
Dikey
Olmuyor
Anlaşıldı
Değil mi?
Yani
Bu
Int
Yıldız
Türünün
Size
Of
Değil
Bakın
Şu
İzleyin
Şununla
Şu
Arasında
Bir
Fark
Yok
Size
Of
Int
Yıldız
Anlaşıldı
Değil mi?
Ama
Burada
Bakın
Bununla
Bunun
Arasında
Fark
Yok
Int
Köşeli
Parantez
Anlaşıldı
Değil mi?
Eğer
Burada
Array
Dikey
Olsaydı
Yenderleyici
A ifadesini
A köşeli
Parantez
0'ın
Adresiyle
Adresine
Dönüştürseydi
Arkadaşlar
Yine
Aynı
Pointer
Size
Of
Değeri
Elde
Hocam
Bunun
Unable
Context
Alakası
Var
Hayır
Unable
Context
O
Başka
Şurayla
İlgili
Uygar
Yani
İfade
İçin
İşlem
Kodu
Üretilmemesi
Yani
Bunda
Oradan
Unavaluated
Context
Alakası
Olduğunu
Söyleyemeyiz
Yani
Öyle de
Belki
Düşünebilirsiniz
Ama
Öyle
Değil
Anlaşıldı
Değil mi?
İfadenin
İşlem
Kodu
Üretmemesi
Yani
Ereğ
Dikey
İşlem
Kodu
Değil
Çünkü
Statik
Olarak
Compile
Time
Yapılıyor
Peki
O zaman
Arkadaşlar
Saat
21.13
Diyelim
Ve
Ara
Verelim
Dakika
Ara
Veriyorum
23.30
Pardon
21.30
Devam
Ediyoruz
Arkadaşlar
Devam
Ediyoruz
Kaldığımız
Yarda
Şimdi
Önemli
Bir
Soru
Daha
Peki
Adresleri
Formatlı
Bir
Şekilde
Yazdırabilir
Mıyız
Standart
Alkota
Bu
Sorunun
Cevabı
Evet
Arkadaşlar
Printem
Fonksiyonunda
Hatırlıyorsunuz
Bir
İfadenin
Değerini
Yazdırmak
İçin
O
İfadenin
Türüyle
Uyumlu
Bir
Conversion
Specifier
Kullanmanız
Gerekiyor
Örneğin
İşaretli
Int
Türden
İfadeler
İçin
Yüzde
D
Float
Ya da
Double
Türden
İfadeler
İçin
Yüzde
F
İşaretli
Long
Türden
İfadeler
İçin
Yüzde
L
İşaretsiz
Int
Türden
İfadeler
İçin
Yüzde
U
Gibi
Bu
Intr
İfadeleri
İçinde
Yüzde
P
Formatlama
Dönüştürücüsünü
Kullanıyorsunuz
İsterseniz
Bir
Deneyelim
Örneğin
X
İsimli
Bir
Değişkenimiz
Olsun
A
İsimli
Bir
Bizimiz
Olsun
Arkadaşlar
P
Tr
İsimli
Bir
Değişkenimiz
Olsun
P
Tr
Değişkenimiz
X
Değişkeninin
Adresiyle
İlk
Değer
Verelim
Bir
De
Pa
İsimli
Değişkenimiz
Olsun
Ona
Da
Adisinin
İlk
Elemanının
Adresiyle
Eredikeden
Faydalanarak
İlk
Değer
Verelim
Yani
Onu
Initialize
Edelim
Şimdi
Bakın
Printf
Arkadaşlar
Adres
X
Eşittir
Yüzde
P
New
Line
Adres
X
Arkadaşlar
Mikroişlemcilerde
Geleneksel
Olarak
Adreslemede
Kullanılan
Tam
Sayı
Sistemi
Eksadesmal
Sayı
Sistemi
Olduğumdan
Printf
De
Yüzde
P
Adresi
Yazdırdığımda
Adresin
O
Sayısal
Bileşenini
Eksadesmal
Sayı
Sisteminde
Yazıyor
Yani
X'in
Adresi
Burada
Şimdi
Adresin
Ne
Olduğundan
Bağımsız
Şuraya
Dikkat
Etmenizi
İstiyorum
Soru
Ptr
Eşittir
Yüzde
P
Ptr
Önce
Soruyu
Anlamaya
Çalışın
Sonra
Cevap
Vermeye
Çalışın
11.
Ve 12.
Satırdaki
Printf
Çağrıları
Aynı
Adresi
Mi
Yazacak
Yoksa
Farklı
Adresler
Mi
Yazacak
Hemen
Cevaba
Bakıyorum
Bir
Arkadaşım
Cevabı
Var
Sadece
Aynı
Evet
Birden
Fazlaymış
Uygar
Umut
Kesinlikle
Çünkü
Bakın
Ptr'nin
Değeri
Zaten
X'in
Adresi
O zaman
Ben
11.
Satırdaki
Printf
Çağrısıyla
X'in
Adresini
Yazdırırken
12.
Satırdaki
Printf
Çağrısıyla
Ptr
Değişkenliğinin
Değeri
Olan
Adresi
Yazdırmış
Oluyorum
O da
X'in
Adresi
Doğal
Olarak
Bu
Adresler
Kesinlikle
Program
Çalışma
Zamanında
Aynı
Olacak
Şimdi
Devam
Ediyorum
Printf
Buraya
Dikkat
Arkadaşlar
A
Eşittir
Yüzde P
New Line
A
Adres
A köşeli parantez 0
Eşittir
Yüzde P
Adres
A köşeli parantez 0
Ve Printf
P A
Eşit
Yüzde P
New Line
P A
Şimdi soruya dikkat
İlk ikisini
Yorum satırına alayım
Ben sormadan
Daha cevabı da geldi ama
Yine de soruyorum
14.
15.
16.
Satırdaki
Printf
Çağrıları
3'ü de
Aynı
Adresi
Yazar mı
Arkadaşlar
Cevap
Evet
E zaten
A ifadesini
Derleyici
A sıfırın
Adresine
Dönüştürüyor
9.
Satırda
Bildirilen
P A
Değişkinliğe de
A
Adresinin
İlk elemanının
Adresiyle
İkiler
Verildiğine
Göre
Yazdırılan
3 adreste
Aynı
Adresler
Burayı anlamanız
Önemli
Süper
Doğru cevaplarla
Geldiğine göre
Anlaşıldığını
Barsayıyorum
Bunu yine
Kodlar
Dosyamıza
Kopyalayalım
Şimdi çok
Dikkatli
İzlemenizi
İsteyeceğim
Bundan
Sonrası
Çok
Önemli
Arkadaşlar
Şimdi
Kodu
Biraz
Sadeleştirelim
İnt
Yıldız
P
Eşittir
Adres
X
P
Poyntr
Değişkeni için
Şunu söyleyebilirim
Değil mi
P'nin
Değeri
X'in
Adresi
Bu cümle
Doğru
Değil mi
P'nin
Değeri
X'in
Adresi
Arkadaşlar
Poyntrlarla
İlgili
Bazı
Konuları
Anlatmak
İçin
Geleneksel
Şöyle
Resimler
Çiziliyor
Bakın
Değişkenleri
Şöyle
Dikdörtgen
Şeklinde
Temsil
Edeceğim
Değişkenin
Değerini
Koda bakalım
Hatta
Kodu da
Buraya
Kopyalayalım
Biraz
Sabırlı
Olmamız
Gerekecek
Evet
Bakın
Şimdi
Bu kod
Birazdan
Kodda
Değiştireceğim
Bu
Koddaki
X
İlişkenin
Runtime
Daki
Durumunu
Göstersin
Değerini
İçine
Yazıyorum
İsmini
Şöyle
Sol
Tarafına
Yazıyorum
X
Adresini
Sağ
Üst
Köşeye
Yazıyorum
Örneğin
Adreste
Ne
Olsun
Arkadaşlar
Sadece
Takip
Edin
Şeklinizi
Açam
Merak
Evet
Şimdi
Bakın
P
Trenin
P'nin
Kendisi
Değişken
Bu
Da
P
Değişken
Olsun
Yine
İsmini
Soluna
Yazayım
Bu
Onun
P
Değişken
Olduğunu
Söylüyor
Fakat
P'nin
Değeri
X'in
Adresi
Yani
P'nin
Değerini
Kullandığımızda
Onu
Bir
Adres
Olarak
Yorumlayacağız
P'nin
Değeri
X'in
Adresi
Şimdi
Çok
Dikkatli
Değişken
Pointer
Değeri
Falança
Değişken
Adresi
Demek
Yerine
Biraz
Daha
İdiomatik
Bir
Söylemle
Şöyle
Diyoruz
P
X'i
Gösteriyor
P'nin
Değeri
X'in
Adresi
Demekle
P
X'i
Gösteriyor
Ya da
Eskilerin
Değişiyle
Göstermek
Yerine
İşaret
Etmek
Fiyili
Kullanırsak
P
X'e
İşaret
Ediyor
Bu
İdiomatik
Söylem
Ve
Daha
Çok
Bu
Tercih
Ediliyor
Yani
Ben
Bazen
P'nin
Değeri
X'in
Adresi
Diyeceğim
Ama
Çoğunlukla
İdiomatik
İfade
Tarzını
Kullanarak
P
X'i
Gösteriyor
Diyeceğim
Ama
İngilizce'de
Durum
Biraz
Daha
Farklı
Derken
Aslında
Farklı
Değil
Sadece
İngilizce'de
Point
Fiyili
Kullanıyor
Ya
Point
Akuzatif
İ
Hali
Değil
Proposition
Kullanıyor
Ve
To
Proposition
Kullanıyor
Yani
Biz
Şimdi
P'nin
Değeri
X'in
Adresi
Bunu
P
X'i
Gösteriyor
Biçiminde
Söyleyebiliriz
Ya da
Ağız
Arkadaşlarında
İşaret
Etmek
Fiilini
Söyleyor
Ben
Gösterici
Diyorum
Onlar
İşaretçi
Diyor
Şu
İşaretçi
Sözcüğüne
Alışamadım
P
X'e
İşaret
Ediyor
P
Bir
Gösterici
Değişken
Onlar
Da
Biraz
Eski
Tercih
Diyorlar
İşaret
Değişken
Ya da
İşaret
Çi
Diyorlar
Hakim
Edebiliyor
Muyuz
Fakat
İngilizce'de
Arkadaşlar
P
Points
X
Demiyoruz
P
Points
To
X
Diyoruz
Zaten
P'nin
Türününde
Pointer
To
Int
Olarak
Söylenmesinin
Nedeni
Bu
Anlaşıldı mı
O zaman
Bir pointer
Değişkenin
Değerinin
Bir Değişkenin
Adresi
Olması
Durumunu
İfade
Ederken
Kullanılan
Tipik
Yapı
O pointer
O değişkeni
Göstermesi
Hatta
Böyle
Çizilen
Resimlerde
Bunu
Biraz
Daha
İyi
Vurguladığı
Düşünerek
Pointer
Değişkenden
Gösterilen
Değişkene
Bir
Okta
Çizerler
Tipik
Olarak
P'nin
Değeri
X'in
Adresi
Demek
P
X'i
Gösteriyor
Demek
Şekilsel
Olarak
Tabi
Bunun
C'nin
Kendisiyle
Doğrudan
Bir
Alakası
Yok
P'den
X'e
Doğru
Bir
Ok
Çiziyorum
Böylece
P'nin
X'i
Gösterdiğinde
Diagramatik
Ya da
Şekilsel
Olarak
Açıklamış
Oluyorum
Buraya
Kadar
Takip
Edebildik
Mi
Ama
Şimdi
Biraz
Daha
Dikkat
Katsayınızı
Arttırmanız
Gerekecek
Çünkü
Biraz
Sizi
Zorlayacak
Bir
Soru
Soracağım
Yukarı
Soldaki
Ve
Sağdaki
Şekille
İlgili
Önce
Şu
Soruya
Cevap
Vermeye
Çalışın
X
Bir
Değişken
Mi
Cevap
Tabi
Ki
Peki
P
Bir
Değişken
Mi
Cevap
Tabi
Ki
X
Bir
Değişken
Olduğuna
Göre
X'in
Bir
Adresi
Var
mı
Cevap
Tabi
Ki
Peki
P
De
Bir
Değişken
Olduğuna
Göre
P
Nin
Bir
Adresi
Var
Cevap
Tabi
Ki
Şimdi
Programcı
Adaylarının
C
De
Zorlandığı
Noktalardan
Biri
De
Bu
Bakın
Eğer
P
Bir
Pointer
Değişkense
P
İle
İlgili
Olarak
İki
Farklı
Adresten
Bahsedebilirim
Biri
P
Nin
Değeri
Olan
Adres
İşte
Bu
Örnekte
P
Nin
Değeri
Kimin
Adresi
X
Diğeri
ise
P
Nin
Kendi
Adresi
Yani
P
Nerede
Sorusunun
Cevabı
Diyelim ki
Nasıl
X'in
Adresi
4500 ise
P'nin
Adresi
Ne
Olsun
Bakın
Şimdi
P
Nerede
Sorusunun
Cevabı
Tıpkı
4500'ün
X
Nerede
Sorusunun
Cevabı
Olması
Gibi
Ama
Arkadaşlar
P'nin
Değeri
P
Kimi
Gösteriyor
Sorusunun
Cevabı
Yani
P'nin
Gösterdiği
Nesne
P'nin
Değeri
Olan
Adresteki
Nesne
Şimdi
Bunu
Kodda
Aslında
Göstermek
Mümkün
Buraya
Geri
Dönelim
Bunu
Kodlara
Kopyalayalım
Ve
Kodu
Biraz
Sadeleştirelim
İzleyin
Önce
X'in
Adresini
Yazdırayım
Printf
Adres
X
Eşittir
Yüzde
P
New
Line
Adres
X
P
Eşittir
Ya da
İsmi
Ptr
Olsun
Biraz
Daha
Kolay
Takip
Edin
Diye
Ptr
Eşittir
Yüzde
P
Ptr
Ama
Bakın
Üçüncü
Printf
Çağrısına
Adres
Ptr
Eşittir
Yüzde P
Adres
Ptr
Şimdi
Soru
Bu iki
Adres
Birbiriyle
Aynı
Adresler
Mi
Cevap
Evet
Ama bu iki
Adres
Aynı
Mi
Cevap
Hayır
İşte
Bakın
Onuncu
Satırdaki
Printf
Çağrısıyla
Ptr'nin
Değeri
Olan
Adresi
Yazdırdım
Ki
X'in
Adresi
Ama
11.
Satırdaki
Printf
Çağrısıyla
Ptr'nin
Kendi
Adresini
Yazdırdım
Şu iki
Adresin
Aynı
Olma
İhtimali
Yok
Çünkü
Biri
X'in
Adresi
Öbürü
Ptr
Değişkininin
Kendi
Adresi
Görüyorsunuz
Değil mi
Adres
X ile
Ptr'nin
Değeri
Olan
Adres
Aynı
Ama
Adres
Ptr
İfadesinin
Değeri
Farklı
O Ptr
Değişkininin
Kendi
Adresi
Şimdi
Bizim
Uzunca
Bir
Süre
İşimiz
Böyle
Adreslerle
Ama
Tahmin
Etmeye
Çalışın
Ptr
Değişkinlerin
Kendi
Adresleri
De
C
C++
Gibi
Dillerde
Kullanılan
İfadeler
Mi
Sadece
Tahmin
Etmenizi
İstiyorum
Cevap
Tabiki
Nasıl
Bravo
Umut
Yağmur
Ama
İşte
Bu
Bizim
İçin
Biraz
İleri
Bir
Konu
Şöyle
Bir
Ay
Buçuk
Bekleyeceğiz
Oraya
Varana
Kadar
Pointer
To
Başlıkta
Önemli
Bir
Dersimiz
Olacak
Orada
Pointer
Değişkenlerin
Kendi
Adreslerinin
Kullanımına
İleşkin
Her
Şeyi
Öğreneceğiz
Buraya
Gelene
Kadar
Bu
Bizim
Birinci
Odak
Noktamız
Olmayacak
Ama
Önemsiz
Olduğu
Anlamına
Gelmesin
Kesinlikle
O
Zaman
Nereye
Geldik
Şimdi
Adres
İfadelerinin
Değerlerinde
Printf
F
Biliyormuşuz
Böylece
Adres
Operatörü
ile
İlgili
Arkadaşlar
Söylenmesi
Gereken
Her şeyi
Neredeyse
Söylemiş
Olduk
Ama
Asıl
Bundan
Sonra
İlerleme
Bir
Hayli
Hızlı
Olacak
Çünkü
İkinci
Pointer
Operatörümüzü
Tanımaya
Başlayacağız
D
Referencing
Operatörünü
Buraya
Kadar
Herhangi
Bir
Sorunuz
Yoksa
Şimdi
Arkanıza
Yaslanıyorsunuz
Ve
Biraz
Zor
Olan
Kısım
Başlıyor
Dört
Tane
Pointer
Operatörü
Olduğunu
Söylemiştik
Biz
Şimdi
Adres
Operatörünü
Mercek
Altına
Aldık
Adres
Operatörü
ile
Oluşturulan
İfadelere
Baktık
Pointer
Değişkenlerle
Bunların
İlgisini
Gösterdik
İlişkisini
Ama
Bu
Arada
Yer
Alt
Başlar
Geçmeden
Önce
Bir
Terimden
Daha
Bahsetmek
İstiyorum
Arkadaşlar
Böyle
Bir
Konumlamadan
Sonra
Şöyle
Diyoruz
Değil mi
Ptr
X'i
Gösteriyor
İngilizce
Ptr
Points
To
X
Arkadaşlar
Ptr
Gösterense
X
Kim
Bunu
Pasif
Hale
Sokun
Gösteren
Pasif
Hali
Gösteren
Gösterilen
Öyle
Değil mi
O zaman
Ptr
Açısından
X'de
Ptr'nin
Gösterdiğiniz
Yani
Gösterilen
İngilizce'de
Böyle
Bir
Terim
Var
Uygar
Yazdı
Bile
Pointy
Bakın
Pointer
Pointy
Ama
İki tane
Eyle
Bitiyor
Tıpkı
Employer
Employeden
Çalıştıran
Sömüren
Arkadaşlar
Employede
Çalıştırılan
Aynı yapı
Değil mi
Pointy
Pointer
Aslında
Böyle
Sözcükler
Çok
Değil mi
Mesela
Uygar bir örnek
Daha vermiş
Caller
Colley
Bir tane
Ben
Vereyim
Payer
Pay
Peki
Şimdi o zaman
Yazılarda
Ya da
Dinlediğiniz
Konuşmalarda
Karşınıza
Çıkanılacak
İngilizce
Sözcüklerden
Biri de
Pointy
Yani
Bir pointer
Değişken
Hangi
Değişkeni
Gösteriyorsa
Hangi
Değişkenin
Adresini
Tutuyorsa
O adresi
Tutulan
Değişkenden
O pointer
Bakış açısıyla
Söz edersek
O da
O pointer'ın
Pointy'si
Evet
Süper
Şimdi geldik
İşin
En önemli
Kısmına
Arkadaşlar
Pointer'lar
Ne işe yarıyor
Sorusuna
Daha değinmedik
Sadece
Elin
Sentaksından
Bahsediyoruz
Ama işte
Pointer'lar
Ne işe yarıyor
Sorusunun
Cevabını
Ya da
Cevaplarını
Anlayabilmemiz
İçin
Bizim
Diğer
Pointer
Operatörüyle
Tanışmamız
Gerekiyor
Hemen
Başlığımızı
Atıyoruz
Başlığımız
D
Referencing
Operatörü
Arkadaşlar
Şimdi bu
Operatörden
Bahsederken
İki tane ayrı isim
Kullanıyor
Biri
D
Referencing
Diğeri
Indirection
Operatörü
İkisi de
Aynı
Anlamda
Bu
Operatör
Başta da
Söylediğimiz
Gibi
Benim
Oluşturduğum
Operatör Öncelik
Tablosunda
Unire
Operatörlerin
Bulunduğu
İkinci
Öncelik
Seviyesinde
Yani
Asla
Bakarsanız
Bakın
Şimdiye
Kadar
Öğrendiğimiz
Neredeyse
Hepsini
Öğrendik
Bakın
İkinci
Öncelik
Seviyesindeki
Operatörler
Hepsi
Unire
Operatör
İşaret
Operatörü
Artı
İşaret
Operatörü
Eksi
Lojik
Değil
Operatörü
Size
Of
Operatörü
Tür
Dönüştürme
Operatörü
Bu
Inter
Operatörlerinden
Adres
Operatörü
Ve
Şimdi
Göreceğimiz
İçerik
Operatörü
Bir de
Bitsel
Bir
Operatör
Var
O
Operatörü
Henüz
Görmedik
Arkadaşlar
Bakın
Bunların
Hepsinin
Ortak
Özelliği
Artı
Bir de
Arttırma
Ve
Eksitme
Operatörlerinde
Koyalım
Bunların
Hepsinin
Unire
Operatörü
Olması
İşte
Buradaki
Operatörde
Bizim
D-referensik
Operatörümüz
Bu
Arada
Tekrar
Bir
Önceki
Ders
Söyledim
Ama
Tekrar
Söylemeye
Uygun
Buluyorum
Arkadaşlar
Nasıl
Buradaki
Ampersan
Günleri
Ve
Operatör
Bu
Arkadaşlar
Adres
Of
Operatörü
Bakın
Sekizinci
Öncelik
Seviyesinde
Oraya
Yine
Geri
Gelelim
Burası
Da
Aradakileri
Yazmıyorum
Sekizinci
Öncelik
Seviyesi
Olsun
Fakat
Buradaki
Ampersan
Bitsel
V
Operatörü
Yine
Bakın
Buradaki
Yıldız
Asterisk
D-referensik
Operatörü
Ama
Hemen
Altındaki
Öncelik
Seviyesinde
Üçüncü
Öncelik
Seviyesinde
Bulunan
Bu
Operatörleri
Hatırlayın
Buradaki
Yıldız
İse
Multiplication
Operatörü
Bizim
İşimiz
Şimdi
Bu
Operatörle
İsmi
Neymiş
D-referensik
Ya da
Indirection
Operatörü
Arkadaşlar
Biz zamanında
CVS Temp
Programajları
Derneğinde
Bu
Operatöre
Şöyle bir
İsim
Taktık
Biz
Uydurduk
İçerik
Operatörü
Diyoruz
Ama
Kullanıp
Kullanmamak
Seç
Kalmış
Önemli
İngilizcesine
Doğru
Öğrenmeniz
Çünkü
Türkçe
Farklı
Karşılıklar
Önerenler
Olabilir
Bu
Operatörün
Unery
Prefiks
Bir Operatörü
Olduğunu
Söyleyerek
Başlayalım
Ne
Yani
Tek Operatörü
Alın
Ama
Önek
Konumunda
Operatör
Yani
Buradaki
Asterisk
Doken'ı
Operatörün
Kendisi ise
Operatörü
Olan
İfade
Operatörden
Sonra
Gelecek
Adres
Adres Operatörü
Böyle
İlgili
Bir
Constraint
Vardı
Adres
Operatörünün
Operandı
L
Value
Expression
Olmalıydı
Ama
İçerik
Operatörünün
Onun da
Bir
Kısıtlaması
Var
Ama
Farklı
Bir
Kısıtlama
Onu
Şöyle
Yazalım
Bir
Kaç
Kere
Tekrar
Edelim
İçerik
Operatörünün
D
Referencing
Operatörünün
Operandı
Bir
Adres
Türünden
Olmak
Zorunda
Yani
Compile
Tanda
Sınanıyor
Eğer
Bu
Şart
Sağlanmazsa
Doğrudan
Sataks
Hatası
Değerli
Arkadaşlar
Mesela
Soru
İzleyin
Yıldız
X
İfadesi
A
Geçerli
Mi
B
Önce
A'ya
Cevap
Veriyorsunuz
Hayır
Geçerli
Değil
Peki
Neden
Geçerli
Değil
Yani
Derleyici
Örneğin
Nasıl
Bir
Sentaks
Hatası
Verecek
İşte
İçerik
Operatörünün
Operandı
Bu
İfade
Mi
Evet
Bu
Bir
Adres
Türünden
Değil
İn
Türden
Değil
İn
Türü
Bir
Adres
Türü
Değil
Dolayısıyla
Arkadaşlar
Derleyici
Durumu
Sentaks
Hatası
Olarak
Değerlendirecek
Yine örneğin
Yıldız
Erör
Değil
Mi
Kesinlikle
Şimdi
Soruya
Cevap
Vermeye
Çalışın
Peki
Şöyle
Olsaydı
Ne
İşe
Yarar
Vesaire
Onu
Söylemeyin
Soru
O
Değil
Daha
Dursun
Yıldız
Adres
Bu
İfade
Geçerli
Mi
Değil
A
Geçerli
B
Değil
Arkadaşlar
Geçerli
Neden
Ne
Anlama
Geldiğinden
Bahsetmiyorum
Burada
Öncelik
Yönü
Soldan
Sağa
Sağdan
Sola
Musa
Ali
Cevap
Sağdan
Sola
Yani
Ben
Böyle
Yazmakla
Aslında
Şöyle
Yazmış
Oluyorum
Değil
Mi
Tamam
Bu
Durumda
İçerik
Operatörünün
Operandı
Bu
İfade
Değil
Mi
Peki
Bu
İfade
Bir
Adres
Türünden
Mi
Cevap
Evet
O
Zaman
Legal
Takip
Edebiliyor
Muyuz
Peki
Devam
Ediyorum
Int
Arkadaşlar
Yıldız
P
Eşittir
Adres
X
Soru
Yıldız
P
İfadesi
Geçerli
Mi
Cevap
Evet
Çünkü
Operant
P
Ve
Operant
Bir
Adres
Türünden
Int
Yıldız
Türünden
Bu
İfade
O
Zaman
Geçerli
Peki
Bir
Soru
Daha
Int
A
Dört
Yıldız
A
Geçerli
Mi
Cevap
Evet
Geçerli
Ama
Ne
Yüzden
Neden
Dolayı
Geçerli
Çünkü
Array
Dikey
Var
Yani
Aslında
A'nın
Kendisi
Doğrudan
Bir
Adres
Değil
Ama
Array
Dikey
Kuralı
Yüzünden
Yıldız
A'nın
Yazmanızda
A
Sıfırın
Adres
Operatörüyle
Eriştiğiniz
Elde
Ettiğiniz
Adresini
Yazmak
Aynı
Anlamda
Dolayısıyla
Nasıl
Burada
Yıldız
Adres
Geçerli
İse
Nasıl
Burada
İçerik
Operatörünün
Operanda
Adres
Operatörüyle
Oluşturulmuş
Bir
İfade
İse
Burada
Array
Dikey
Uygulandıktan
Sonra
Yine
Aynı
Şekilde
İçerik
Operatörünün
Operandı
Bir
Adres
Olacak
O zaman
Burada
Anlamadığımız
Bir
Şey
Var mı
Son
Kez
Tekrar
Edelim
Ne
İşe
Yarayacağını
Birazdan
Konuşacağız
Ama
İçerik
Operatörüyle
Oluşturulmuş
Bir
İfadenin
Geçerli
Olabilmesi
İçin
İçerik
Operatörünün
Operandının
Bir
Adres
Olması
Gerek
Yok
Ama
Bakın
Bu
Adres
Az
Ancak
Örneklerde
Gördüğünüz
Gibi
Bir
Pointer
Değişkenle
Oluşturulmuş
Bir
Adres
Bilgisi
Olabilir
Adres
Operatörüyle
Oluşturulmuş
Bir
Adres
Bilgisi
Olabilir
Ya
Da
Bir
Dizi
İsminin
Ereğ
Dikeyle
Dizinin
İlk
Elemanının
Adresine
Dönüştürülmesi
Sonucu
Elde
Edilmiş
Bir
Adres
Bilgisi
Olabilir
Buraya
Kadar
Tamam mı
Tamam
Şimdi
Geldik
En
Kritik
Cümle
İçerik
Operatörü
Artık
Bu
Termin
Anlamda
Kullandığımı
Biliyorsunuz
Operanda
Olan
Adresteki
Nesneye
Erişim
Sağlar
Yani
Bakın
Yıldız
Adres
Ne
Anlama
Geliyor
Adresteki
Nesne
Yani
İçerik
Operatörünün
Operanda
Hangi
Nesnenin
Adresi
Yıldız
Yazıyorum
Açık
Yani
İçerik
Operatörünün
Operandı
Hangi
Nesnenin
Adresi
İse
Oluşturulan
İfade
O
Nesnenin
Kendisidir
Şimdi
Bakın
Bu
Çok
Önemli
Çünkü
Öğrencilerde
Şöyle
Bir
Yanlış
Anlama
Oluyor
Ben
İçerik
Operatörü
Şöyle
Bir
İfade
Oluştursam
Örneğin
Söyleyin
İçerik
Operatörünün
Operanda
Hangi
Nesnenin
Adresi
Cevap
X'in
O zaman
İçerik
Operatörü
Bizi
Hangi
Nesne
Yeriştirecek
X'e
Yani
Böyle
Yazmakla
X
Yazmak
Arasında
Bir
Fark
Yok
Ama
Nedense
Ben
Öğrencilere
Sorduğum
Zaman
Bu
İfade
X'in
Değeri
Ben
X'in
Değeri
Değil
Bu
İfade
X'in
Kendisi
Ama
Tabiki
Değer
Olarak
Da
Kendisi
Olduğuna
Göre
Aynı
Değerdir
Şimdi
Gelin
Bunu
Gösterelim
Arkadaşlar
Sırasıyla
Az Önce
Yazdığımız
Geçerli
İfadelere
Bakalım
Yılgız
Adres
X
Arkadaşlar
Sadece
Göstermek
İçin
Pratikte
Böyle
Bir
İfade
Yazmanızın
Makul
Olacağı
Bir
Senaryo
Yok
Obfascation
Dışında
Niye
Böyle
Bir
İfade
Yazayım
Ki
Çünkü
Böyle
Bir
İfade
Yazmakla
X
Yazmak
Aynı
Anlamda
Obfascation
Ne
Olduğundan
Bahsetmiştik
Değil
Mi
Mesela
Soru
Böyle
Bir
Kod
Yazsam
A
Sentaks
Hatası
Var
mı
Cevap
Hayır
Çünkü
Böyle
Yazmakla
X
Yazmak
Arasında
Bir
Fark
Yok
Peki
Dolayısıyla
Kimin
Değerini
Yapmış
Olurum
Tabi ki
X'in
Değerini
İsterseniz
Bakın
8.
Satırda
Daha
O
İşlem
Kodu
Yürütülmeden
X'in
Değeri
İdi
Ama
12.
Satırdaki
Print
F
Çağrısı
X'in
Değerini
Ne
Olarak
Gösterdi
Çünkü
Aslında
Bu
Hatama
X'e
Yapıldı
Bakın
Şimdi
İzleyin
Biraz
Eğlenelim
Bunlar
Right
Associative
Operatörler
Değil
Mi
Evet
Aynı
Seviyede
Ama
Sağdan
Sola
Peki
Şöyle
Bir
Şey
Yapsam
Artı
Yıldız
Adres
X
Böyle
Yazmakta
Artı
X
Yazmak
Arasında
Bir
Fark
Yok
Değil
Ali
Evet
O
Zaman
X'in
Değerinin
Şimdi
Olduğunu
Söyleyebilir
Miyiz
Cevap
Tabiki
Arkadaşlar
Bana
Şunu
Sormayın
Muhtemelen
Sormak
İstiyorsanız
Niye
Böyle
Bir
Kod
Yazayım
Yazmam
Zaten
Böyle
Kodlar
Konunun
İyi
Anlaşılmasını
Sağlıyorlar
Peki
Tekrar
Verleyip
Çalıştıralım
Ve
Gerçekten
X'in
Değerinin
Obfuscation
Olsaydı
Arkadaşlar
Bakın
Şöyle
Bir
Kod
Yazsaydım
Ya
Bu
X'in
Adresindeki
Nesne
O
Zaman
Tekrar
Adresini
Alayım
Tekrar
Bu
Adresteki
Nesne
Yerişeyim
Hatta
Bunu
Şu
Hale
Getireyim
Burada
Da
Nesnenin
Değerini
Bir
Arttırayım
Arkadaşlar
Evet
Böyle
Bir
Kodu
Neden
Yazayım
Yazmam
Ama
Sentence
Açısından
Halen
Hiç
Bir Problem
Yok
Öyle
Değil
Mi
Evet
Peki
Bu
Kod
Yürütüldükten
Sonra
X'in
Değeri
Ne
Olacak
Cevap
Yine
Artacak
Herhangi
Bir
Şekilde
Sentence
Atası
Yok
Kod
Son
Derece
Legal
Evet
Tabi
Arkadaşlar
Yanlış
Anlaşılmasın
Diyor
Ki
Uygar
Assemble
Tek
Satır
Maludur
Tabi
Ki
Yani
Siz
Böyle
Yazıyorsunuz
Ama
Derleyicinin
Bakış
Açısıyla
Bu
Demek
Yani
Sonuçta
Bunların
İfade
İçinde
Alması
Gözlenebilir
Davranış
Değişmediği
İçin
Tabi ki
Assemble
Kodu
Olarak
Bakarsak
Aynı
Koda
Karşılık
Geliyor
Bravo
Uygar
Hep
Bu
Tür
Durumlarla
Neyi
Düşüneceksiniz
Observable
Behavior
Değişmiyorsa
Derleyici
En
Sade
Kodu
Üretmeye
Çalışıyor
Ki
Burada
Hiçbir
Problem
Yok
Peki
Soruları
Biraz
Değiştirelim
Arkadaşlar
Int
A
Eşittir
Yıldız
A
Eşittir
Peki
Burada
Ne
Oluyor
İçerik
Operatörünün
Operandı
Hangi
Adresse
İçerik
Operatörüyle
Oluşturulmuş
İfade
Bizi
O
Adresteki
Nesne
Yeriştiriyor
O zaman
Bu
Adres
Ereğ
Dikeyle
Dizinin
İlk
Elemanının
Adresi
Olduğuna
Göre
Dizinin
İlk
Elemanına
Yerişiyorum
Yani
Değeri
Dizinin
İlk
Elemanına
Tanıyor
Değil
Mi
Kesinlikle
Hatta
Bakınız
Printed
Yüzde
D
New
Line
Biraz
Daha
Uzun
Yazın
A
Köşeli
Parantez
Sıfır
Eşittir
A
Köşeli
Parantez
Sıfır
Dokuzuncu
Satırdaki
Deyim
Yürütülmeden
Dizimizin
İlk
Elemanının
Değeri
İdi
Ama
O
Kod
Yürütüldüğünde
Dizimizin
İlk
Elemanının
Değeri
Değişti
Ve
Oldu
Görüyorsunuz
Değil
Arkadaşlar
Daha Şimdiden
Subscript
Operatörünü
Mercek
Altına
Almasak
Dahi
Bir
Şeyi
Rahatlıkla
Söyleyebiliriz
Değil
Dizinin
İsmi
Olmak
Üzere
Are
Bir
Bizi
Olmak
Üzere
Are
Köşeli
Parantez
Sıfır
Yazmak
İle
Yıldız
Are
Yazmak
Arasında
Hiçbir
Fark
Yok
Bunlar
Tamamen
Birbirine
Eş
Değer
İfadeler
Anlaşıldı
Mi
Are
Bir
Dizi
Ismi
Olmak
Üzere
Are
Köşeli
Parantez
Sıfır
Yazmak
Yıldız
Are
Yazmak
Arasında
Bir
Fark
Yok
İkisi
De
Aynı
Anlamda
Dolayısıyla
Ben
İçerik
Operatörün
Operandanı
Bir
Dizi
İsmi
Yaparsam
Bu
Örnekte
Olduğu
Gibi
Bu
İfade
Dizinin
İlk
Elemandır
Peki
Bu
Söylediklerimden
Hareketle
Şu
Cümle
Hakkında
Yorum
Yapar
Mısınız
İçerik
Operatörü
İle
Oluşturulan
Tüm
İfadeler
Tabi
Geçerli
Tüm
İfadeler
Söyleyin
Bakın
Cümleyi
Tamamlayın
A
L
Value
B
R
Value
Cevap
Tabiki
Nesne
Gösterdiğine
Göre
L
Value
Expression
Değil
Şimdi
Gelelim
En önemli
Kullanım
Biçimine
Enter'dan
Bir
Değişkenimiz
Olsun
Ve
Ben
Bu
Değişkenin
Adresini
Bir
Pointer
Değişkene
Atayım
Ya da
İlk
Değer
Olarak
Vereyim
Şimdi
Bunu
Şöyle
İbadettik
Değil
Mi
P'nin
Değeri
X'in
Adresi
Ama
İdiomatik
Söylem
Biçimi
Şöyleydi
Ömer Kara
P
X'i
Gösteriyor
Kesinlikle
Arkadaşlar
O Zaman
İçerik
Operatörünün
Operandını
P
Yaparsam
İçerik
Operatörünün
Operandının
Değeri
X'in
Adresi
Olduğuna
Göre
İçerik
Operatörü
De
Bizi
Operanda
Olan
Adresteki
Nesne
Yeriştirdiğine
Göre
Yıldız
P
Demek
Ne
Cevap
Yıldız
P
Demek
X
İşte
Bunu
Ben
Sorduğum
Zaman
Yıldız
P
Ne
Diyorum
X'in
Değeri
Diyorum ki
Hayır
X'in
Değeri
Değil
Yıldız
P
X'in
Kendisi
Yani
Yıldız
P
İfadesi
Bize
X'in
Kendisine
Eriştiriyor
Örneğin
Yıldız
P'ye
Değerini
Atarsam
Bu
Değeri
Kime
Atamış
Oluyorum
Tabii ki
X
Değişkenini
Atamış
Oluyorum
Bakınız
Yıldız
P
Eşittir
Atama
Deyiminden
Önce
X'in
Değerini
Yazdırdığımda
Yazacak
Ama
13.
Satırdaki
Printif
Yazacak
Yine
Right
Associative
Olduğunu
Da
Göstermek
İçin
Artı
Yıldız
P
Yazarsam
Aslında
Sanki
Burada
Bir
Öncelik
Parantezi
Varmış
Gibi
Yani
Yıldız
P
Nesnesinin
Değerini
Arttır
Anlamına
Geliyor
Yıldız
P
Nesnesinde
X'in
Kendisi
Olduğuna
Göre
X'i
Arttırmış
Olacağım
Ve
17.
Satırdaki
Printif
Çağrısı
Arkadaşlar
Hangi
Değeri
Yazdıracak
X'in
Değişmiş
Olmuş
Değerini
Yazdıracak
Peki
Şimdi
Size
Kafanız
Karışacak
Karışmayacak
Bakalım
Göreceğiz
Önemli
Sorular
Soracağım
Konunun
Anlaşılması
İçin
Bence
Çok
Önemli
Hadi
Bakalım
İnt
X
Eşittir
İnt
Yıldız
P
İnt
Yıldız
P
Int
Yıldız
P
Artı
Yıldız
P
Artı
Yıldız
P
Artı
Yıldız
P
Bu kod
çalıştığında
Bu kodun
oluşturduğu
sonuç
nedir?
Evet
Sizde
Uygar
Sizde Uygar
Bey'in cevabını
mı
veriyorsunuz?
X
Eşkin
Kesinlikle
Arkadaşlar
Bakınız
P1'e
ilk değer
olarak
X'in
adresini
verdim
P2'ye
ilk değer
olarak
P1'in
değerini
verdim
P3'e
ilk değer
olarak
P2'nin
değerini
verdim
Şimdi
Buraya
geldiğimde
P1'de
P2'de
P3'de
X'i
gösteriyor
diyebilir
miyiz?
Ömer Osman
Koyuncu
Cengiz
zor
görmez
Tabii ki
P1'in
değeri de
P2'nin
P3'ün
değeri de
X'in
adresi
O zaman
Yıldız
P1'de
X
Yıldız
P2'de
X
Yıldız
P3'de
X
Ve ben
aslında
artı artı
operatörün
operandı
farklı
değişkenlerle
oluşturulmuş
ifadeler
olmasına rağmen
aynı nesne
Şimdi bu
neden
indirection
operatörü
dendiğini de
gösteriyor
Arkadaşlar
biz şimdiye
kadar
X'in
değerini
yazdıralım
gerçekten
Hem
böyle
hem de
bu deyimden
önce
üçgen
altı
olduğunu
bir
görelim
Arkadaşlar
şimdi bakın
bu zamana
kadar
bizim
bir değişkeni
kullanabilmemiz
için o değişkenin
ismini yazarak
bir ifade
oluşturuyorduk
ama şimdi
bir değişkeni
kullanmanın
bambaşka bir
yolunu
daha gördük
eğer
kullanmak
istediğimiz
değişkenin
adresini
tutan
bir pointer
değişken
varsa
yani
bir pointer
değişken
o
değişkeni
gösteriyor
ise
pointer
değişkeni
dereferencing
operatörünün
operandı
yaparak
arkadaşlar
ben
onun gösterdiği
nesneye
erişebilirim
yani
kodda şu anda
X'in
ismi yok
farklı farklı
üç değişken
ismi var
ama
tabiri caizse
derler ya
ismi yok
cismi var
X'in ismi yok
ama cismi var
çünkü
yıldız P1
demek
X
yıldız P2
demek
X
yıldız P3
demek
X
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
şimdi bunu da
kodlara koyalım
biraz daha
kafanızı karıştırmaya
çalışalım
tabi kafanızı karıştırmaya
çalışmak kötü
niyetli değil
daha karmaşık
gibi görünen
kodlara bakıp
bilgileri
oturtmak
pekiştirmek
amaçlı
3 tane değişkenim var
bir de pointer değişkenim var
söyleye bakalım
şimdi bu pointer değişkenim
kimi gösteriyor
X'i
çünkü P3'yi
X'in adresine atadım
o zaman
yıldız P3
kim
cevap
X
o zaman
örneğin bu atamayı
kime yaptım
X'e
ama şimdi
P3'nin değerini
değiştireyim
Y'nin adresi yapayım
peki
yıldız P3
eşittir
şimdi bu atamayı
kime yaptım
G değişkenine
yaptım
P3'nin
değerini
değiştireyim
Z'nin
adresi yapayım
şimdi bu atamayı
kime yaptım
Z değişkenine
yaptım
bu da bizim daha önce
deneyimlemediğimiz bir durum
bakın aslına
bakarsanız
13.
15.
ve 17.
satırdaki
deyimlerde
atama operatörünün
sol operanda
aynı ifade
değil mi
eğer bilmesek
aynı ifade
atama operatörünün
sol operanda
olduğuna göre
bütün bu atamalar
aynı nesne yapılmış
algısına
kapılabiliriz
ama öyle değil
P3'nin değeri
arada değiştiği için
burada yıldız
P3
demek
X
burada yıldız
P3
demek
Y
burada yıldız
P3
demek
Z
dolayısıyla ben
bu atamaları
sırasıyla
X
Y
ve Z
değişkenlerini
yapmış oluyorum ki
X değişkeninin
değerini
Y
değişkeninin
değerini
ve
Z
değişkeninin
değerini
yazdırdığımda
3'ünün de
değerinin
değişip
olduğunu göreceğiz
Anlaşıldı mı?
Evet
Şu pointerlarla
ilgili
aldığınızı
önce
hiç acelemiz yok
yavaş yavaş
bu operatörlerle
arttırmaya
çalışacağım
izleyin
int x eşittir
int y eşittir
int yıldız
P1
eşittir
X'in
adresi
int yıldız
P2
eşittir
Y'in
adresi
Yıldız
P1
çarpı
eşit
Yıldız
P2
bölü
eşit
arkadaşlar
bu kodda
herhangi bir şekilde
bir
sentaks
hatası
var mı?
Yok
Peki
aslında
buradaki
yıldız
P1
X
olduğuna
göre
X'i
ile çarpmış
olurum
değil mi?
Dolayısıyla
X değişkeninin
değeri
arkadaşlar
ile çarpmama
göre
olur
benzer şekilde
yıldız
P2'de
Y
olduğuna
göre
Y değişkeninin
değeri de
arkadaşlar
4 olur
değil mi?
Ama ben
X'in değerini
yazdırayım
Y'nin
değerini
yazdırayım
Peki
şimdi
soruya
bakın
izleyin
Bunlar
kalsın
Yıldız
P1
eşittir
Yıldız
P2
Arkadaşlar
bu kodda
herhangi bir şekilde
bir sentaks
hatası
var mı?
Cevap
hayır
Peki
söyleyin
Yıldız
P1
hangi nesne?
P1'in gösterdiği nesne
yani X
Yıldız
P2
hangi nesne?
P2'nin gösterdiği nesne
yani Y
O zaman bu adama
aslında
X eşittir
Y yazmaktan
başka bir anlama
gelmiyor
değil mi?
Bravo
Yani
X değişkeninin
değeri
bu adamadan
önce
10 idi
bu adamadan
sonra
ona
Y'nin
değerini
atadığımız
için
20 oldu
Takip edebiliyor
muyuz?
Peki
bir soru
daha
bakalım
bu sefer
sizi şaşırtmaya
çalışacağım
şaşırtabilecek miyim?
Hadi bakalım
dikkat takip edin
artı artı
yıldız
P1
Ben hangi
değişkenin
değerini
bir arttırdım?
X'in
Peki
şimdi
koda bakın
int
yıldız
Ptemp
eşittir
P1
P2
eşittir
Ptemp
artı artı
yıldız
P1
eksi eksi
yıldız
P2
O da
bakın
Arkadaşlar
bu kodu
olmasaydı
yorum satırına
alıyorum
yıldız
P1
X olduğu
için
X'in
değeri
artacaktı
yani
olacaktı
yıldız
P2
Y olduğu
için
Y'nin
değeri
eksilecekti
ve
olacaktı
ama
şimdi
soruya
dikkat edin
sizce
bu
deyim
yürütüldükten
sonra
ne oluyor?
P1
ve P2
takas ediliyor
P1
ve P2
takas edilmesi
ne demek?
P1
X'i
gösteriyorken
Y'yi
gösteriyor
hale
gelecek
P2
de
Y'yi
gösteriyorken
X'i
gösteriyor
hale
gelecek
dolayısıyla
şimdi
tam tersi
artı
yıldız
P1
Y'nin
değeri
olacak
eksi
yıldız
P2
X'in
değeri
olacak
anlaşıldı
mı?
Tabii ki
nasıl
iki tane
tam sayı
değişkenin
değerlerine
takas edebiliyorsam
iki tane
pointer değişkenin
değerlerini de
takas edebilirim
P1 ve P2
takas etmek
demek
P1
P2'nin
değerini
alacak
P2 de
P1'in
değerini
alacak
yani
P1
X'i
P2
Y'yi
gösteriyorken
tam tersi
P1
Y'yi
P2
X'i
gösteriyor
hale
gelecek
anlaşıldı
mı?
Evet
arkadaşlar
demek ki
içerik operatörüyle
ben
bir adresteki
nesneye
erişebiliyorum
şimdi
pointerların
ne işe
yaradığına
yavaş yavaş
artık
D-referencing
operatörünü
öğrendiğimiz
için
gelebiliriz
arkadaşlar
daha önce
fonksiyon
çağrılarının
bu tarz
programlama
dillerinde
call by value
ve call by
reference
olarak
tipik
iki kategoriye
ayrıldığını
söylemiştik
elinizde bir değişken
var
ve bu değişkeni
bir fonksiyon
çağrısında
kullanmak
istiyorsunuz
eğer fonksiyon
çağrısı
call by value
ise
fonksiyona
değişkenin
değerini
gönderiyorsunuz
fonksiyona
değişkenin
kendisini
göndermiyorsunuz
yani bu durumda
fonksiyon
sizin
değişkeninizin
değerini
kullanabilir
ama
sizin değişkeninizi
değiştiremez
çünkü onun
değerini
fonksiyonun
parametre değişkenini
kopyalıyorsunuz
fakat fonksiyon
çağrısı
call by
reference
ise
değişkenin
kendisini
gönderiyorsunuz
demektir
bu programlama
dilinden
bağımsız
kullanılan
terimler
yani
örneğin
bir değişkenin
değerini
başka bir
fonksiyonun
değiştirmesini
istiyorsanız
call by
reference
olmak zorunda
ama amacınız
değişkenin
değerini
değiştirmek
değil
sadece değişkenin
değerini
input olarak
fonksiyona
göndermekse
call by value
işinizi
görür
ve demiştik ki
kursun başında
fonksiyonlar
konusunu
gördüğümüzde
c dilinde
bütün fonksiyon
çağrıları
default olarak
call by
value
hatta şu örneği
hatırlıyorsunuz
bakın
tekrar yazalım
void
who
int
a
a eşittir
bu
a
soru
bu nokta
a diyorum
x
soru
bu noktada
x'in değeri
onken
fonksiyon
çağrısından sonra
x'in değeri
olur mu
cevap
tabii ki
hayır
çünkü buradaki
a değişkeni
x'in kendisi
değil
yani aslında
bu fonksiyon
x değişkenini
değiştirmedi
fonksiyon
kendi parametre
değişkeninin
değerini değiştirdi
yani buradaki
atamada
a
x değişkeninin
kendisi
değil
zaten a
değişkeni de
bu fonksiyonun
kodunun
çalışmasıyla
hayatını
yitiriyor
değil mi
çünkü otomatik
ömürlü bir değişken
dolayısıyla
bu şekilde
bir fonksiyon
çağrısı
yaparak
bizim
bir fonksiyonun
yerel değişkenini
başka bir fonksiyona
gönderip
onu değiştirmesini
sağlayamayız
peki
call by reference
olması için
ne yapacağız
işte
c dilinde
call by reference
pointer semantiğiyle
gerçekleşiyor
ben bu fonksiyonun
parametre değişkenini
bir
pointer değişken
yaparsam
o zaman
bu fonksiyona
x'in
adresini
gönderirsem
bu fonksiyon
çağrıldığında
fonksiyonun
parametre değişkeni
olan pointer
argüman olarak
gönderilen
x'in adresiyle
değerini almış
olacak
yani
a
parametre değişkeni
x'i gösteriyor
olacak
o zaman burada
a7 referans
bahsettiğimde
bu fonksiyona
hangi nesnenin
adresi gönderilmişse
o adresteki
nesneyi
değerine getirmiş
olacağım
işte bu
call by reference
daha önce
böyle bir
imkanımız yoktu
arkadaşlar
kıssadan ise
uzun uzun
anlatacağım ama
pointer'ların
kullanıldığı
tek yer
olmasa da
en fazla
kullanıldığı
yer
bir fonksiyonun
parametre değişkeni
pointer yap
böylece bu fonksiyona
bir nesnenin
adresi gönderirsin
ve fonksiyonun
kodunda da
o pointer'ı
d-referans ederek
yani içerik
operatörünü
operanda yaparak
adresi gönderilen
nesnenin
kendisine eriş
mesela
bakınız
diyelim ki
neden fonksiyon
yazıyoruz
valla fonksiyonların
belki de
ilk varlık
nedeni
bir sürü
farklı varlık
nedenleri var
ama
sık yapılan
işlemleri
her defasında
kodu tekrar
etmek yerine
tek bir yerde
tutmak
bir soyutlama
yapıyorsunuz
mesela
en sık
yapılan
işlemlerden
biri
swap
değil mi
şimdi düşün
ne zaman
swap yapmak
istesem
şu kodu
yazmak
yerine
ki
değişken
isimleri
de farklı
olacak
o zaman
bu işi
yapan
bir fonksiyon
tasarlarsam
oluşturursam
ne zaman
swap yapmak
istediğimde
o fonksiyonu
çağırdım
izleyin
a bir değişken
b bir değişken
şimdi şöyle bir fonksiyon
yazmak istesem
swap
a virgül
b
bu fonksiyonun
a ve b
değişkenlerini
takas edebileceğini
söyleyebilir miyiz
a evet
b hayır
cevap
tabii ki
hayır
çünkü bu
call by value
hiçbir şekilde
böyle bir fonksiyon
a'nın ve b'nin
kendisine
erişemez
ama
diyelim ki
dile hakim
değiliz
ve gerçekten
böyle bir
swap fonksiyonu
yazma
girişiminde
bulundum
int
temp
eşittir
x
x eşittir
y
y eşittir
temp
swap
fonksiyonu
bu şekilde
çağırdığımızda
a ve b
değişkenlerini
takas etmiş
olduk mu
alakası yok
fonksiyonun
parametre
değişkenlerini
takas etmiş
olduk
dolayısıyla
a değişkeninin
değeri
halen 5
b değişkeninin
değeri
halen
peki
gerçekten
swap
fonksiyonu
oluştursaydık
ki
oluşturacağız
en sık
ihtiyat
duyulan
fonksiyon
ve maalesef
böyle
standart
bir
c
fonksiyonu
yok
bir kere
mutlaka
ve mutlaka
fonksiyonun
işini
yapabilmesi
için
fonksiyona
a ve b
değişkenlerinin
değerlerini
değil
adreslerini
göndermem
gerekirdi
bu durumda
fonksiyonun
parametre
değişkenleri
adres tutan
pointer değişkenler
yani pointer
to int
değişkenleri
olmalıydı
o zaman
bu fonksiyonda
aslında
arkadaşlar
yıldız x
demek
birinci parametreye
adresi gönderilen
nesne
demek
yani
bizim örneğimizde
yıldız x
a'nın kendisi
yıldız yeri de
b'nin kendisi
o zaman
böyle bir kod
yazarsam
bu fonksiyona
hangi iki nesnenin
adresini gönderirsem
o iki nesne
takas edilmiş oluyor
işte ilk
gerçekçi
işe yarayan
pointer parametreli
fonksiyonumuzu
yazmış olduk
şimdi bu fonksiyonla
ilgili birkaç soru
sorsam
arkadaşlar
izleyin
int
x eşittir
int y eşittir
arkadaşlar
buradaki
x ve y isimlerinin
fonksiyonun
parametre değişkenleri
olan x ve y isimleriyle
hiçbir alakası yok
değil mi
sadece isimler ortak
ama sizi rahatsız ediyorsa
birine a birine b
diyeyim
int
yıldız p1
eşittir
adres a
int
yıldız p2
eşittir
adres b
soruyu anlamaya çalışın
swap
p1
p2
sizce 17. satırdaki
fonksiyon çağrısında
bir hata var mı
bir yanlışlık var mı
var ya da yok
deyin
yok diyor
Umut Uğur Cengiz
peki 17. satırdaki
fonksiyon çağrısı
a ve b'yi
takas eder mi
swap eder mi
cevap
tabi ki
evet
bravo bravo
bravo
çünkü
ben fonksiyona
p1'in
değeri olan adresi
gönderiyorum
p1'in değeri
x'in adresi
ikinci parametreye de
p2'nin değeri olan
adresi gönderiyorum
yani aslında
swap fonksiyonunu
bu şekilde çağırmakla
adres
a
b
biçiminde
çağırmak arasında
bravo
Uğur Ün
hiçbir fark yok
dolayısıyla
kodda hiçbir hata yok
ve bu kod
çalıştıktan sonra
arkadaşlar
a'nın değeri
333 olacak
ve
b'nin değeri
arkadaşlar
591 olacak
peki bir soru daha
günün son sorusu olmaya
aday
vaktimiz
tamamlanıyor
peki ikinci soruya
bakın
arkadaşlar
şöyle olsaydı
int
a
3-5-8
int
b
2-4-6
swap
a-b
bu kodda
yanlışlık
bir hata
var mı
cevap
hayır
yine burada
array dikey oluyor
değil mi
aslında
a yazmakla
a dizinin
ilk elemanının
adresini
b yazmakla
b dizinin
ilk elemanının
adresini
kullanmış oluyorum
yani aslında
yukarıdaki
fonksiyon çağrısı
aşamadaki
fonksiyon çağrısına
eş değer
her ikisi de
a dizinin
ve b dizinin
ilk elemanlarının
adresleriyle
çağrılıyor
dolayısıyla
yukarıdaki
swap
fonksiyonu da
adresini
aldığı
iki nesneyi
takas ettiğine
göre
aslında
arkadaşlar
a dizinin
ilk elemanıyla
b dizinin
ilk elemanı
takas
edilmiş
oluyor
peki bugünkü
dersimizde
pointerler
konusunda
bir giriş
yapmış olduk
bir dahaki
hafta
daha yüksek
tempoyla
hızlı bir şekilde
ilerleyeceğiz
ben Necati Ergin
derse katıldığınız
için teşekkür ediyorum
salı günü
özür dilerim
pazartesi değil
görüşmek üzere
herkese
iyi bir hafta sonu
diliyorum
hoşçakalın
değerli arkadaşlar